This is Jocko podcast number
69 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Yeah.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
The president of the United States takes
pride in presenting the metal of honor
posthumously to Captain Henry,
t l Rod United States Marine Corps.
Okay.
For Service as set forth
in the following citation.
Okay.
For conspicuous gallantry and
interpretative [inaudible].
Okay.
At the risk of his life above and
beyond the call of Duty Wall attached to
marine of fighting squadron 211 during
action against the Japanese land surface
and air really units at wake
island from eight to 23 December,
okay.
Engaging vastly superior forces
of enemy bombers and warships.
On nine and 12 December,
Captain El Rodd shot down to have a
flight of 22 hostile planes and executing
repeated bombing and strafing runs at
extremely low altitude and close range.
Succeeded in inflicting deadly
damage upon a large Japanese vessel,
thereby sinking the first major war ship
to be destroyed by small caliber bombs
delivered from a fighter type aircraft.
Okay.
When his plane was disabled by hostile
fire and no other ships were operative.
Captain El Rod assumed command of one
flank of the line set up in defiance of
the enemy landing and conducting a
brilliant defense enabled his men to hold
their positions and repulsed,
determined enemy attacks repeatedly
proceeding through intense hostile few
salons to provide covering fire
for unarmed ammunition carriers.
Okay.
Capturing an automatic weapon
during one enemy rushing force.
He gave his own firearm to one of his
men and fought on vigorously against the
Japanese.
Okay.
Responsible in a large measure
of the strength of his sectors.
Gallons resistance.
On 23 December,
Captain El Rod led his men with bold,
aggressive aggressiveness
until he fell mortally wounded.
Okay.
His superb skill as a pilot,
daring leadership in unswerving devotion
to duty distinguished him among the
defenders of wake island.
Yeah.
And His Valliant conduct reflects
the highest credit upon himself.
Okay.
And United States naval service.
He gallantly gave his
life for his country,
signed Harry s Truman,
and that is the medal of honor
citation for Henry Talmage l Rod,
the first aviator in world war two to
be awarded the medal of honor and the
first man to sink a warship
from a fighter plane.
Okay.
During the battle of wake island.
And if you don't know anything
about the battle of wake island,
it began simultaneously with the attack
on Pearl Harbor when that started,
and it ended on 23 December,
1941 when American forces
were forced to surrender,
then that was with around
500 American servicemen.
And they had a handful of
coastal artillery pieces and
a handful of antiaircraft
guns and they had 12 aircraft.
And what they were facing was 2,500
Japanese infantry supported by three light
cruisers, eight destroyers to
patrol boats, to troop transports,
to aircraft carriers with all their
planes and too heavy cruisers.
So you were completely outnumbered
and completely and utterly outgunned.
But they held out for 15 days and
while they were under that siege
on the 20th of December,
while the Japanese were
preparing for their final attack.
Okay.
Major El rod got out one
last letter to his wife.
Okay.
They're not going to read that to you.
Saturday 20 December,
1941 my dearest darling sweetheart,
I never suspected this afternoon
when I wrote my other short note,
but I would be sitting down writing
another tonight. But here we are.
I just got in a few minutes ago and
I've just learned that Walt Baylor is
returning and he has kindly consented
to deliver to this personally.
So I am very thankful for the moment.
Of course there isn't a lot of news that
I can write about and you probably know
more real news than I do.
Anyhow.
I am missing you terribly and I'm
undergoing a few new experiences,
but also is everyone else.
We've had considerable rain
today and it is still cloudy.
The wind has been very low.
However,
the weather on the whole is
nothing to complain about.
But I would like to see
a good old fashioned ties
foun sweep this entire area.
I imagine there was an awful lot of white
washing going on now in high places.
It's certainly will be a criminal
shame if they succeed in covering over
everything.
I am writing this in something of a
hurry and under somewhat difficult
circumstances.
I'll think of a million things that I
should have said after I had gone to bed
tonight.
But now I'm going to say that I love
you and you alone always and always and
repeated a million times or so.
Give my love to Mary. Also
between the two of you,
you have it all.
There isn't any for anyone else.
I know that you are praying for me and
I have nothing more to ask than that.
Your prayers be answered.
Yours devotedly and loving
Talmage.
Yeah.
And so I think it's important
that,
but when you hear that letter,
you recognize the fact that this is a,
this is a man.
And of course we always remember that
these men,
we call them,
we called them heroes, deservedly. So.
We do that to honor them.
But I think it's important
to always remember
that these heroes,
there are people,
they're people
and these men, these
heroes, these marines,
these people that held the line,
they held the line for 15 days
before they were forced to surrender.
After losing 49 Marines killed,
two missing in action.
Three navy personnel killed
70 US civilians killed.
And by the way,
the Japanese losses were recorded
about 820 killed with over 300 wounded,
two destroyers lost
and almost 30 Japanese
aircraft shot down or damaged.
But the odds in the
ratio of force was just stacked against,
okay,
the u s forces on wake island. And when
you get into a situation like that,
a dire situation,
no violence situation,
a situation where you are
facing a determined enemy,
there is
a bond that forms between
people regardless of where
they're from or what their
background is or what their socio economic
classes or what service they were.
And none of that matters.
There's a bond that forms
that cannot be broken.
And we certainly had that
in the battle of Ramadi,
US Army soldiers,
United States,
marines,
CBS,
our seals of task unit, bruiser, bruiser,
all of us that were in
that fight had that bond.
We were brothers
and tonight
I am honored to have one of those brothers
here with me
and he's a Marine Corps aviator,
a fighter pilot
who also did time as a forward air
controller on the ground and we've talked
about that in many of the books that
we've reviewed on the podcast where you
have a marine corps pilot who's
now on the ground with the troops,
usually in one of the most
forward positions because
they have to know where the
troops are
out of that
air conditioned cockpit and into
the sweat in mud on the ground.
And this,
this pilot as an Anglico team leader
who with his team conducted dozens and
dozens of missions with task unit
bruiser in Ramadi and I've talked about
bringing him on the show
and so here he is tonight,
lieutenant colonel almost retired,
David Burke.
Dave,
welcome to the podcast and
thank you for coming on.
Thanks for having me, man.
It's going to be here.
So we have to,
before
we talk about what we
went through together,
we have to learn a little bit about you,
where you of came from,
what you did and how you
went from being from being a,
you know, a pilot but not
just a pilot, a top gun pilot,
but not just the top gun pilot
but a but a top gun instructor,
which is just incredibly selective.
That's gotta be one of the most selective
things in the whole world. Right.
How many top gun pilots are there?
See about 25 at a time.
Every three years they kind of
rotate through small group. Yeah.
So that's a ridiculous,
and, and then, you know,
you've thought maybe I, you need
to get after it a little bit more.
So you're going to go do an egg coastal.
We'll get into that.
But let's start off with,
with where you came from.
Just a little bit about your background
and how you ended up saying, you know,
when I think I want to do, be in the
Marine Corps. Yup. Go right on. Um,
so I actually grew up around here.
My parents moved out here in San Diego
and I was probably a year and a half
years old. I wanted a half years old
in between here in Orange County.
I grew up in southern California kid.
I'm not all that exciting with childhood.
I don't have a ton of crazy memories.
I was a pretty quiet kid.
He's a good kid in school.
Got Along with most folks. Um,
mood at Orange County.
My parents got divorced.
It was basically just me and my mom
and my sister for awhile. And, uh,
I lived in a town called El Toro.
And what happened to be very close to
where I grew up was a marine base as a
fighter base.
And so as a kid,
I pause there and late
seventies and early eighties,
they had f four phantoms and a fours and
a six isn't just the cool jets at the
time. And so, uh, I went
to the air show every year,
grew up out there and I think
it was no joke, it was overhead.
I could see it in every day. And I think
that has gotten my blood a little bit.
Uh,
went to El Toro high school,
went to the air show probably every year
from last six years old til the time
that base closed down. No joke. I mean
it was just part of my life. And uh,
you know, I met some people
along the way too. You know,
there's a lot of marines live in there,
so I had some real powerful influences
that kind of guided me towards that. Um,
I'm sure we're going to get into this
because it's come up already in the pre
conversation, but in around 14, let's say,
watch this obscure movie
called a top gun trade up top.
The Guy Straight up man, uh,
watch the movie as a kid. Uh,
saw dude's flying airplanes off carriers
shooting down megs and I'm like,
I want to do that.
And probably by 14,
I had a pretty good idea. That's
what I wanted to do. Um, did,
did you make the connection between
school and grades and all that stuff?
Because a lot of people saw that movie and
said, Oh, I want to be a top gun pilot,
but I'm still going to slack off and
do whatever I want and not, you know,
play hooky and all that.
Somehow you made that connection.
It's not shown in the movie.
Right.
They didn't show people studying hard in
school because that would have not sold
a lot of tickets. I
did eventually. I mean,
when I watched that movie,
I think they're just something I,
I'd always been interested in aviation.
It's kind of captivating when you see
planes flying around and gets in the air
show, see the blue angels,
that kind of stuff.
You can't help a look up and
watch that stuff. It's cool. Um,
I would say that my performance in the
academic arena was slightly less than
stellar. I was, I did fine, but I had
no real motivation to do anything. Um,
I wasn't a real driven kid
to, uh, to work really hard.
I kind of discovered that if I put
in very little effort, I was okay.
And if I wanted to do really well,
how to put in a lot of effort and
I hadn't made much of a connection,
but so as I got a little older, you know,
you know, I watched the movie, you know,
I think I was a part of a lot of different
things. But about the time I was 16,
so kind of junior year in high school,
um,
as I got some other influences in my
life and my biggest one was a guy named
Aaron urban.
I started working at target around the
corner from my house and as a marine
there. And like I said, my
parents got divorced. Um,
I had a stepdad that was there
and kind of come and gone.
He ended up being a really big father
figure in my life and a real positive
influence and a marine,
which was great.
And he explained some more things about
what it's like to be a marine. He,
he's the one that made the connection
for me that all that stuff you saw in the
movies, you can actually do
that for real. The Marine Corps,
you can do that as a marine. You know,
it's not just a movie that's a real life.
Somebody is living that life right
now and you can do that. And uh,
I remember coming home and kind of telling
my mom like, Hey, I'm, you know, I'm 16,
I'm a junior high school. I'm thinking
about being a Marine Corps fighter pilot,
which I had no military in my background.
Nobody had ever done anything
like that. And her answer was, uh,
sounds awesome. You should do that.
I mean, just a hundred percent.
And she had a very similar approach.
Uh, you know, everything, every,
every idea I've ever had in my life that
I run by my mom, she was like, well,
is going to do it might as well be you.
That was kind of our approach to
everything. I want to be a fighter pilot,
the marine corps, someone's going
to be, it might as well be you.
And that's about the time I kind of
started getting my stuff together a little
bit. I wasn't a mass but
by any stretch, but I,
I was a little bit just
kind of running through.
I do my thing being a kid and um,
uh,
I certainly think I was lucky because I
knew with great detail at about 16 and
change what I wanted to do.
I mean I knew I wanted to be a marine
corps fat and pilot based in southern
California and if we'll have carriers
and that's exactly what ended up doing.
So at that time everything has started
to do from there was with that kind of
singular focus of
circling back to do that.
I even knew I wanted to be stationed at
El Toro and I had a real specific plan.
And so all of the things I started doing
from their school into college as well,
uh, go into the marine recruiter to
say I wanted to join the marine corps,
be an officer in the Marine Corps.
All those things were geared very
specifically towards that goal.
And now there's a ton of horror hurdles
between the time you're 16 and time.
I got my commission at 21,
but everything else that I did in my life
was either a distraction that just got
rid of or it was a means to that end.
Uh,
I worked full time while I was in school
putting myself through the nearest
college. Uh, you know, the, the local
state school that I live close to.
I just drove up to school,
didn't have like a real big exciting
college life in a fraternity.
It didn't go away to school.
Uh,
I paid my way through a school
and I got a good education.
I worked really hard to, to, to do well,
but it was all specifically designed to
do you want to be in the Marine Corps
and be an officer? You need
a college graduate, you need
to be a college graduate.
Right on. I can do that.
I can do that here.
Closest College towards the courses
in college. Uh, how much does it cost?
How much do I need to work?
Did the math.
It was my life from about that time
I started working at, like I said,
I worked at target as a kid.
I worked at target from the time I was
15 and a half and got a work permit from
school to the time that I
got my commission in the
Marine Corps and I went to
school and cal state Fullerton
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
My mom was a guidance
counselor and a teacher,
so she helped me build a schedule that
I could graduate as fast as possible,
which is exactly in four years.
It was all day Monday,
all day Wednesday and half a day Friday,
and I worked Tuesday, Thursday, Friday,
Saturday, Sunday. The money I paid,
I got paid. I went to my tuition,
my tuition went to my education,
my education got me a commission in the
Marine Corps. I mean, that was kind of it.
I mean in some ways you look back,
I'm probably could have
diversified a little bit,
but at the time I wasn't unhappy.
I was, I was stoked, man.
I was exactly what I wanted to
be doing. There was no like, man,
I wish I could be doing this. It wasn't
a chore by any stretch. Like I said,
in retrospect, I probably could have
done things a little bit differently.
But 17 year old day,
Burke,
18 year old Dave Burke knew exactly
what he wanted to do and I had sort of
talked myself into it like,
hey,
any detour that's going to
throw you off your path man,
and you're going to look
back with regret and go,
you know why you didn't have been what
you wanted to be because of this or that.
And I wasn't going to let that happen.
So I kinda just got a little intense
about being out of the Marine Corps.
And sure enough they did. And you're
still luck involved. Cause when you go to,
when you go to TBS,
which is the basic school,
which is all marine officers go through,
you,
you have to still win or,
or get that bill wanted and you got that.
But I mean that could have
gone totally mad sideways.
There's a lot of luck involved.
Um,
I think everybody in the military and
everybody that had been successful in the
military knows you looking
back on your career. You know,
it's a confluence of a lot of
different things, but timing,
circumstance and luck or they're
a part of it without a doubt. You,
nobody can take credit for
everything they've done.
And I went back to do it again.
The odds of it working out the
way that it did are pretty slim.
There's just a lot of things that worked
out in my favor. Um, but you know,
I went to ocs,
I went to the Marine Corps recruiter.
I started my freshman year at
cal state Fullerton as a sub.
I was 17 when I started college.
Went right to the recruiter on day one,
or they call it an Oso and
officer selection officer.
So it's basically a recruiter
for officers. Hey, I want
to be a marine. He's like,
right on start filling out this paperwork,
filled out the paperwork. I said,
I want to be a Powerade is like piece
of cake. No problem. We can get,
we can make that happen.
Uh,
sign this ground contract and we'll
just make it pilot at some point in the
future. For those of you that
don't know, that's a big lie.
A dead easy. It's what he
says, ground chart contract.
Of course the Marine Corps needs
pilots and guys to infantry and so,
but they need more infantry then they
need pilots. And so they say, hey,
don't worry about it.
You just sign up for ground right now.
We'll take care of that other pilot. You
want to be Pi? Yeah, yeah, of course.
We'll take care of that later.
Yeah, we'll just transition over.
It shouldn't be a big deal,
no factor. And at 17, I mean,
I was signing paperwork to be a marine
officer. That was a big step for me and I,
and I probably would have signed
anything, uh, happily sign that. Um,
after my freshman year in college,
I went to officer candidate
school and to be honest with Ya,
and I had all these big grand ideas
for the last two, three years,
I knew what I wanted to do,
but I, when I went to ocs,
that was the first real hurdle. I mean
everything else you do that or an idea,
a plan, some paperwork I
get to the officer candidate
school and it's like okay,
it was a Royal Marine drill
instructor screaming at you, you know,
you're really doing the deed there.
And getting through ocs was a big thing
for me because it was the first real
test of did I, you know, I knew what I
wanted to do but I had no real sense of,
I had what was required to be a marine
and I think as a kid you build up what
that is in your mind.
Is that the larger than life thing?
Like how could anybody possibly do this?
You turn it into something more than it
is. When I went to bootcamp, there was a,
there was a navy seal there,
right?
And I swear when I saw him I was
like, God, look, now you need huge,
huge,
I mean huge,
big giant forearms and
just a big massive guy.
It just looked like a destroyer of
human life. And I was, oh my God.
So fast forward four years,
I'm in the teams and I meet this
guy. And he's not at all, man.
He was completely in my head.
It was completely in my head.
But this guy was such a destroyer.
But I just thought, hey, he's a seal.
He must be a destroyer. And I
actually saw it that way. Yeah,
you can't help. And it's certainly
at that age, I mean those,
those things are real powerful influences
and wanting to get out to ocs and all
of a sudden you're like, oh man, I
need to, I didn't make this happen. Uh,
that was a big, big achievement in my
life that said, hey, I can do this. Okay.
I started to realize I'm not the
biggest guy in the marine corps.
Nobody's going to mistake
me for a destroyer. Um,
but what I discovered as I got there,
I knew mentally what I wanted to do.
It wasn't a real question mark
about my intentions are my desires.
And I was surrounded by
tough, strong kids. You know,
young kids my age that are trying
to be marine officers. And that's,
that's a physical and a mental challenge.
There's no doubt about it.
And I was seeing guys kind of left and
right of me that looked at least bigger,
faster, stronger, tougher and more
capable than they looked like that,
that same image you have in your mind.
And I'm watching these who's
kind of fall out of stuff.
We're not finished stuff fast enough.
We're just straight up quit. Um, you know,
guys would deal our drop on request at
ocs and I was kind of looking around.
I'm thinking, what's, you know,
what's going on? You know,
why are you here if your plan wasn't
to get through it? So that was a good,
a really good thing for me psychologically
to realize that it wasn't just a kind
of a fantasy or a dream I had,
I had the potential being able to do this.
So I got through ocs. Um, you know, that's
kind of a painful process as you know,
it's 84 days. It can
be, it can be slogging.
You lose a lot of folks doing it for
a whole host of different reasons.
Some people get hurt, some people
quit, some people just can't do it. Uh,
and when you get on the backside of that
and like I can, I can make this happen.
Let's get that air contract.
Well we'll get to that.
Her contract at the basic school,
which is when you get your commission,
you finished school, you get your
degree, finish officer candidate school.
And so basically it says, Hey,
you've done everything you need.
You're a commissioned officer,
became a second one 10 in the Marine
Corps in June of 1994 and the first thing
you do on active duty as a marine and he
would go to something called the basic
school.
I know you've talked about it a few times.
It's basically a school for the Marine
Corp teaches officers a little bit of
everything. It doesn't teach
you everything of anything,
but you get a little exposure
to infantry exposures, tanks,
artillery call for fire.
It a little exposure to aviation
patrolling defense offense.
So you kind of get all the way on the
land and the whole point of that for the
Marine Corps,
you go there with 250 people and they
got to give each one of those people on
assignment, you know, a particular
job and Mos a specialty. Um,
and they rank you,
I mean you are ranked from
one to 250 and for aviation,
when I got there,
I remember getting in the first week
they kind of announced what billets are
going to be a bill available. Oh,
we're going to have, you know,
40 infantry slots and 2010 yeah,
they just tell you I kind of
what we expect to have breakdown.
And from there you're supposed to go
back and think about what you want to do.
They had to pilot slots. I'm like,
man, that is some rough math. You know,
250 folks now, not all tuned to
50 wanted to be a pilot obviously.
And not all 250 people were qualified
with, you know, their eyes and what not.
So it wasn't competing with 250 people,
but there was a lot of people
that want to be a pilot.
So the math was certainly not in my favor.
And that was another challenge of yeah,
you got to do well.
I mean you get ranked and graded
on everything. Physical fitness,
your leadership ability or academics,
you get peer reviewed,
you know your peers rate you and you know
anonymously and what they think of you.
So you've got basically six months to
get accurate and at the end they line you
up 250 people in a line,
not, this is a real line.
And you walk into a room and on the
room there's a board and whatever job is
available,
you can pick.
Now the Marine Corps does
this thing called quality
spread or they basically cut
the class in third. So
had a 250 folks, you know,
80 80 80 or something around there.
The number one guy ethics.
Then the number 81 guy picks and then the
number 161 guy picks or whatever it is.
And then the number two guy picks.
The only job in the Marine Corps that
they did not quality spread was at the
basic school was pilot.
So it was going to be the
first two guys out of the gate.
They wanted it that we're qualified,
we're going to get it.
And I got the number
two spot. Um, so again,
it was one of those things that I'm,
I,
I was starting to in my mind
realized like, Whoa, this,
I can do this. Uh, you know,
I built this thing up or what I
wanted to do. I'm 21 now, you know,
22 I think actually,
so it's six years of my life that I've
been sort of singularly dedicated doing
this. And so that day where they, my
platoon commander, guy named John Mary,
and I'll never forget it,
he was an [inaudible] pilot,
brings me into his office.
It's like, Dave, you're going
to be a pilot. And he goes,
I think you're going to
fly America's airplane.
We're gonna fill out the fat and horny. It
was an awesome day, man. And, uh, I won't,
I won't ever forget it. And, um, that
was it. You know, I got my ticket.
I, when I, when I was selected
for a pilot, I was ranked,
I think number eight and a 250 in my
company. And by the time I graduated,
like three weeks later,
I was like 25 out of two 50.
So my performance might have declined a
little bit after I had achieved in the
theory of no slack,
a little slack in that line.
That line was pretty tight
for a lot of years. Got It.
So a little bit of slack there
at the end, but I did finish, uh,
you know it well enough to get that
pilots, which is what I always wanted.
It was kind of my dream. And
uh, that was April of 1995.
So I started the basic school in
October of 94 right after I got,
I graduated college in June,
a little delay to get down to Quantico
for the basic school that's six months
long. I graduated sometime mid April and
we'll wow about this time in 1995. So,
and then you go to flight school,
you do the rag,
do all that stuff to get out to a,
and then the first kind of work you were
doing was a, was southern watch, right?
Yeah. So I get through flight
school, like ended up picking fat.
I get stationed at Eltoro.
So I am literally living the dream.
I moved back to my hometown.
Um,
I think I went until like my 10 year
high school reunion and you know,
I had told all my buddies,
you know, we wanted to do,
I ran into some people I hadn't seen
in a while. It was, it was good. Um,
and uh, shortly after I got
there, I actually flew the
last flight out of El Toro.
They closed the base and all the marines
moved down to Miramar. So the navy were,
top gun was filmed and all that stuff.
Back in the day the navy left San Diego,
moved back east and the Marine
Corps happily took over that base.
And so I moved down to Miramar,
ended up in an fat in squadron,
stationed at Miramar,
flying Hornets off carriers,
straight up live in the shool dream.
You are now living at this time.
That's, that's, that is exactly
right. I'm living in San Diego. Uh,
I was living in PB off Anna Kappa and
I'm stationed Miramar Flying Hornets and,
and the carrier that I was assigned to,
uh,
my first deployment we did Operation
Southern Watch. So, you know,
I watched Desert Storm
in [inaudible] 91 on TV.
I was in freshman in college and you know,
we hadn't,
we hadn't done much in
the military since then,
but we had flown every single
day since the war ended in,
I think was it march of 91
every single day since then.
And we flew patrols over Iraq to make
sure that the skies were clear and we were
enforcing the no fly zone. And here
it was, you know, 10 years later,
2000 on a carrier in the Persian
Gulf flying combat operations,
uh, over southern Iraq. Did you guys
ever dropping bombs there? I did, yeah.
A few of us did, not a ton,
there wasn't a ton going on,
but what we would do these
things called response options.
So if that rack is would do something,
I think in my case they set up a
surface air missile south of, uh,
of a line that they
weren't supposed to be.
And we had surveillance and
told us what was out there.
And I launched on a mission,
I'm blew up a Sam site with something
called a j damn at the time was a,
it was a bomb
guided by GPS, which at the time
was this brand new and crazy.
That was crazy technology.
I think we are on the only plans in the
entire carrier that could do it cause we
had this thing called a gps
super fancy back then. Um, but,
but at the time jacket, that was
combat. That was, that was it.
There was no other show in town.
And so the night that I dropped a bomb
on a Sam site in Iraq off a carrier and
an f 18 you'd, I could have, you
could have just retired right there.
We're done under to go. Yeah, I was
at, I could've come back to that.
It could have phoned me off the ship and
I probably would have died a happy man
at that point. I was like, that's it.
I, I've, I've reached critical mass.
That's all I ever wanted to
do. So it was, um, again,
a lot of it was just things
worked out in my favor,
but I did exactly what I wanted to do.
And that event was,
was kind of at the time,
sort of the pinnacle.
That was what I thought I
was going achieve. Yeah.
I mean it's the same thing in
the dry years for the seal teams.
Like if you did some kind of mission, you
are just super stoked. Dude. You know,
we were over in the Persian
Gulf actually same time,
2099, 2000 I was there, I was in
the Persian Gulf and we were doing,
you know, meo operations stop
and smugglers coming out of Iraq.
So we were taken down vessels and getting
control of them. And again, at the time,
super stoked.
Yes.
The big mission was taking all these
vessels and you thought it was pretty cool
in a way. It was cool. It was cool,
but you just didn't have any anything
to compare it to at all? Yeah.
So then what happened? So I get
back from that deployment, uh,
that's the summer,
summer of 2000 and shortly after that I
got selected by my commanding officer to
go to top gun.
So that was my first exposure to kind
of advancing inside the squadron.
So I was a young guy,
had done almost two years in the squadron,
had been there for a little while and uh,
got some qualifications and grew
and developed in the squadron.
And they pick one or two guys every couple
of years from me squash and to go to
the school.
And the whole point of going there is a,
you learn kind of this advanced,
you know,
it's like a master's degree basically in,
in being a fighter pilot with the intent
that you can bring that back to the
squadron and be one of the kind of key
trainers are key leaders in the squadron.
So I went to top gun uh, early
the next year, a summer of,
actually about a year later,
so summer of 2001, uh,
I go to top gun and I came back and
we're just in a work. I was like,
when you show up to top gun, just
sort of Reno's, yeah, you feel like,
I mean especially because you were the
big combat vet with the bombs dropped and
you feel like you're pretty
much a complete stud and
then you show up at top gun
and the instructors just can completely
annihilate. It just furthers.
You don't know. It's, it's,
you're learning how dogfight w Mano Imano
against another guy and another plane
like stock car racing because the planes
are equal and it's you against the
other guy.
And it was actually cool.
You were explaining some of the rules
and how you'd set it up and they have,
you know, in Jujitsu you know, you, you,
you okay. You know, you start standing,
you know, you shake hands,
bump fists, okay, now it's on,
well with the top gun they
started a certain distance. They,
they go towards each other. At a certain
altitude, certain away from each other.
They go, they pass at a thousand feet,
you know, left, left wing, the left wing.
And then once they pass they said, what
do you say? Game on fights on fights,
on fights on, and then boom, now it's go.
So that's how they start
in a neutral position. And,
and of course when you show up there,
it's just like Jujitsu and the fact that
it's like a guy that did a little bit
of training somewhere and then they show
up at a Jujitsu place and they're going
to get totally destroyed. So he shows
up, you show up at this thing and,
and you think you're again, big combat
vet, you just get annihilated. Totally.
So yeah, I get the, I had
dropped a bomb that's singular.
I had dropped a bomb and
bomb and I was, I was, yeah,
it was a big deal I'd do that. Dropped a
bomb, you know. And so at the time I was,
I think some of the instructors
had never done that before. Right.
Most of them are, like you said, there's
the dryers. It just wasn't a ton going on.
You know, how to, a story
here and there. But, um,
I think more than anything in my own
mind, you, you kind of build up. Like,
I got some game here, man.
I'm going to watch this.
I'm going to do some good work
here. Uh, and you know, I'd,
I'd done well enough on my squad and then
I was one of the guys that got picked
to go to school. So, which is another
little confidence boost. Yeah. It is.
Ego's getting fed, forced fed
maybe. Yeah, a little bit.
Um, yeah, you're feeling pretty good about
yourself and so you'd go up there and,
uh, like, like you said, so you know,
you're, you're a student. You know,
you're not going to, you know, you're not
going to be as good as the instructors,
but we, you don't know is that you're not
just going to lose, you're going to get,
you're not just going to
lose or get annihilated.
You're not even know what happened.
It's going to be over and you're going
to kind of be flying back and before
you're going to land in
and you're not going to be,
have explained what just occurred. I
mean, it occurs in a way that it's so,
it's hard to explain. It's
like you weren't there. Uh,
it's really, it's humbling. I mean, Jocko,
we're talking the very first flight on
the very first day, my very first event,
the very first fight of the first flight,
it was over in like 20 seconds.
And the instructor was saying,
okay, let me call it and say,
knock it off when we're done,
we're going to start and set it up again.
And I knew right then, I was totally in
over my head, the very first one. And uh,
it was so, my first flight was,
was so bad that when I landed, um,
we're walking back in to you go to
maintenance and you basically go back and
turn the airplane back in
and so they can fix it.
And then what you're supposed to do is
walk across street to the squadron hanger
and talk about it.
And I'm in my gear and you're supposed
to get undressed out of your flight gear
and go and he's like, Hey, don't get
undressed. And uh, I'm like, okay. Right,
right on. He's like, why don't
we just go do that again? Um,
it was bad enough that we didn't
even need to talk about it.
We just need to just hey. And he's
like, hey, why don't you just,
just take a deep breath man.
And we went and did that flight without
ever without ever even talking about the
first one. Right. Um, so I
kind of knew I was, yeah,
I had some work to do. So top gun is, is
really good about not just humbling you,
but obviously it teaches
you a ton. It's, it's a,
it's a six at the time it was only
six weeks with the marines because we,
we didn't do some of the syllabus at the
Navy did cause we've got it elsewhere
and it's six.
You start with literally
just you against another guy won against
one and you end up building up to where
it's a,
you know,
six to eight of you on the front on the
blue side of the friendly side against,
you know, 15, 20 simulated
adversary. So it's uh,
it's a lot in a short period of time and
that idea of being like really bad and
when you start happens over
and over again in the course.
So you get to the one B one phase
and at the end and like, oh,
finally I got this one be one thing,
I got this thing wired, I can do this.
I'm like, all right, cool. You're
not going to go to against whatever.
And you just get rolled again and
you're like back to square one.
So it builds you up and breaks you down
and build you a standard military and
you know,
just breaks you down to your pieces.
And then the guys there
that are instructors are so,
they're obviously really good. I mean
that part is sort of speaks for itself.
They're really good on the airplane.
But what makes them unique is
that they're exceptional teachers.
So you learn a ton.
So by the time,
by the time you finished up gun that
that image in the mirror and you're like,
man, that dude was awesome.
That gets shattered. It's
actually all back together.
By the time you leave as the you leave,
they're like,
you got that patch on your
shoulder and you fly back.
You'd get the patch and the last day
you'd get up in your airplane and fat with
my name painted on the side with a top
gun patch and I flew back to Miramar,
see the dream better
dream is getting better,
but there's been enough reminders or like,
uh,
I should probably maybe cool
out a little bit. You know,
you start to just learn that there's
always guys out there that are
significantly better than you and
you keep climbing up the hill.
But finishing top gun as a student,
you feel like you've hit the top
of the mountain. But you realized,
cause the guys you've been working with,
there's an awful long way to go.
You at least know what you don't know.
That's a great way to put it.
You know what you don't know and you're,
there's a lot that you don't know.
And so it kind of dispels
all those feelings. You know,
we went through flight school,
like, wow, I finished flights going,
I gotta fight teens, I've really got
this flying thing nail. And you're,
you're barely functional and an
airplane compared to these other guys.
And when you get to a place like top gun
and it's just such a concentration of
talent, you, you, it's good
as it feels. You actually,
the thing that you get
the most out of there,
some humility because you just got crushed
for six weeks, crushed, crushed, uh,
and hopefully you learn
something out of it.
And you supposed to take that back and,
and teach the guys in your squadron,
all those same lessons.
And so my expectation was I was
going to go back from top gun.
I was gonna spend another two years,
18 months in the squadron as a kind of
the senior instructors and then go on to
something else. And then, and I didn't
know exactly what that was at the time,
but as I'm leaving, no joke, my last
day, I remember the guy who asked me, um,
it's actually the same guy that's going
to do my retirement here in a couple
months. And he's like, hey man,
have you thought about coming back to
being an instructor top gun after this
tour? And your squad comes over? And I
tried to play it cool. Like, oh, it's, Oh,
let me,
let me go home and think about that.
But clearly there wasn't a
lot to think about there.
So I left there with kind of an
inclination that I might get asked back.
And I was pretty stoked about that.
And they didn't formalize it,
but he was a senior Ip on the staff,
the senior marine in there as well. Um,
a real respected guy in marine aviation.
And he had give me a sit down.
So I was hoping that that was gonna
happen. But I also thought I had time.
I thought I was, you know, this is 2001
and obviously, you know, six weeks later,
a nine 11, uh, hits. And so all that
calculus kinda changed. And very quickly,
my squadron,
which was on this regular cycle of
preparing to go to what was going to be
another southern watch deployment, just
like we did, that whole thing had changed.
Um, because, uh,
because of September 11th through what
happens on September 11th for you? Yeah.
You were an active in a squadron getting
ready for work in the morning totally.
Whom? I'm station right up
the road here. Uh, you know,
five miles north of here isn't Marine
Corps Air Station Miramar. I'm a mom.
My second half of my first tour as
a pilot and [inaudible] squadron,
I'd already done that one deployment.
And um, I had a routine down, you know,
I was getting up, I was probably, I guess
it was probably five in the morning.
I'm sitting at the foot of my bed,
lacing up my boots like I did every day
to just get in the car and drive into
work and click on the TV. And, you know,
I see say eight o'clock back east or,
or around that time and I see what's
going on. And I think, you know,
same story for all of us. Kind of piece
it together very quickly. Like, Hey,
this isn't an accident,
this is something's really happening here.
You see if the second building and it
very quickly kind of clicks in like this
is the real thing. Um, and I knew, I knew
something I knew were going to go to war.
I didn't know what.
I obviously didn't know the details,
but I knew things were going to change
really dramatically. As a matter of fact,
you know,
my drive to work,
which normally would have taken
me 10 minutes or whatever,
15 minutes, something,
some short drive to get up into,
into the base.
It was like three hours to
get on the base. You know,
they're inspecting every vehicle,
you know,
every car getting pulled over or dogs
or you know, the whole nine yards.
Just the security. Uh, it was pretty
chaotic. He was kind of mayhem. And,
um, I drive into my squadron and half
of my squadron had already, not half,
but a good number of guys had
already been up to Fallon,
which was where we're going to go for
training, the same place the top gun is.
And it was just part of
a normal training cycle.
And my squadron commander at the time,
uh,
an awesome guy called me because he
had gone up there and I was supposed to
bring the, you know, be part of the second
half of that went up there. He's like,
hey man,
you need to go brief.
You're going to be the lead of
a four ship of aircraft. Uh,
we don't know all the details yet, but
we're gonna, they're gonna call you,
they're going to find a live ordinance
and you're going to have to fly an
emission, uh, uh,
an air patrol competent or virtual mission
and it up the cap because there were
still a bunch of airliners that we're
still airborne coming in from places like
Japan and Korea, these long haul,
you know, 12, 13, 14 hour flights.
There's a whole bunch of airplanes
airborne. And we didn't know if those,
there's potential issue with
those airplanes, you know,
if they're going to try to
do the same thing back east.
So they did out west total chaos and,
and I had just recently graduated from
top gun, so I was, he'd say, okay,
you're the lead. And, and
we didn't have a good,
we didn't know what the mission was.
I mean,
it was basically one of those things
where we're supposed to get airborne and
somehow between us and
some other controller,
we're going to kind of determine
if a particular aircraft
might've been a threat.
And that was happening all over the
country. People were in their aircraft,
air force, Navy, Marine pilots.
We're just launching to do
these protection missions
of what ends up becoming
something called a Operation Noble Eagle,
which started on September 11th.
And it was this aviation, Overwatch
of, of cities and, and key locations.
And we were totally clueless on what
that was. Now, I ended up not launching.
That didn't happen. Um, you know, but we
did the brief, we're getting ready to go.
And, uh, it was just kind of that moment
of chaos of we're on our heels and
talking didn't prepare me for that.
I didn't have a sense of what I'm
supposed to do with an airliner, you know,
filled with civilians on some route
coming from Japan and trying to figure out
what I would do if somebody
said, hey, that aircraft,
we figured out that aircraft is going
to try and fly into a building or,
or crash into an airport or
something like that. It was just,
you're just kind of mayhem
and, and it was, uh, you know,
it's tough to start off the idea being
that if that is suspected of happening or
they can somehow confronted,
that's going to happen,
then you or one of your mates is
going to have to shoot down a civilian
aircraft. That's what your
being, that's what they're,
that's what they're
thinking. Yeah, exactly. And,
and that was something I'd
never considered. Um, you know,
there's anybody you'd consider it at
that point. And I've read, there's some,
you know, there's some
pilots that actually ended up
launching in the east coast.
I've read a couple articles of pilots
that took off from there f six sixteens
here in DC because obviously
it was with the Pentagon, uh,
up in DC and the New York City that
actually did get airborne and they had
missions to do exactly that.
Um,
so in some sense I was pretty lucky
that I didn't have to go through that
calculus,
but I still can picture where I'm
sitting given that brief with three other
pilots, Kinda like we're sitting today and
we're even asking ourselves like, well,
how do you, I mean, how do you shoot
down an airliner? You know, what,
what would we actually go through to do
that? How would we determine, you know,
when we were kind of trying
to talk through that and,
and the idea that an airliner filled
with civilians and we knew at that point
that those other airliners are versus
regular commercial airplanes that just
took off to go on their
flight and they had crashed.
When you have everybody on board, you
know, nobody's gonna survive that.
And so it was just a very
strange way to start.
What ended up being kind of
a cycle of war that you know,
we've all been through for years now on
that morning of getting that call from
the CEO, Hey, this is what you're doing.
And you know, that was the beginning, um,
shortly, very shortly after
that. Within a day or two, no,
actually I think probably that late
afternoon and certainly by the next day my
squadron was one of the several squashes
that was tasked to go back out on the
carrier. So we split that squash and
a half, that same CEO that called me,
he took guys from Fallon,
flew onto the ship onto the carrier
right off the coast of lax. Uh,
and I still, we, we talked about
this I can picture to this day.
I took off out of San Diego
and it's flying overhead,
Los Angeles International Airport.
And we had guys that taken
off from the carrier.
They had live missiles and they were
doing a cap and I'm flying, you know,
kind of opposite direction overhead,
lax looking down. And you know,
I grew up in southern California.
Lex is like one of the
busiest airports in the world.
There's planes all over the tarmac on the
runways and the taxiways cause there's
everybody landed,
nobody took off,
there's no controllers and they're
doing this cat mission when they're just
flying overhead. Lax kind of
largely unknown of what's going on.
And just that moment of seriality of
them airborne and there's nobody else,
nobody else flying. And we're just sort
of just waiting for something to happen.
And you know, it was kind of one
of those, hey, you'll get your,
you'll get more specific instructions
as we figure it out. You know,
the leadership was,
was scrambled every bit as much as we
were and kind of looking down thinking
this is, this is a whole new world.
You know, this is not southern watch.
You know that that mission
we've been doing. And within
maybe six weeks, we steamed out, we take,
we loaded the carrier a
couple months early, put the
squadron, the whole airwing,
got on board the carrier and steamed out
towards the north Arabian Gulf to go do
what we call it as Operation
Enduring Freedom. So late 2001,
I think it was maybe November of
2001, we were going to war. Uh,
and Afghanistan was where the war was.
You remember at the time that was it.
There was nothing else going on.
And we went to Afghanistan.
So I did a seven month
cruise on a carrier, um,
from November of 2001 I
think we came back April,
may of 2002,
uh,
and did combat operations over
Afghanistan and you know, you know,
a lot more ordinance and a lot busier.
We did a mission at the time
was called Operation Anaconda.
Thinking about Ashley about that,
that was like the largest ground offensive
we had supported since Desert Storm.
Um, and when we came back in
April, April or May of [inaudible],
we thought we would sort
of largely won the war.
We thought we'd accomplished most of
our mission. We left thinking, Hey,
this thing is winding down.
We're feeling pretty good about it.
And when I got back in May of o two,
I kind of distinctly remember like I
just had my war experience, you know,
as a pilot in combat. And, you know,
I'd done Southern Watch, but obviously,
you know, nothing like this. And, but I'd,
I'd done a combat deployment off a
carrier supported troops on the ground in
Afghanistan, dropping bombs and fallen
off cares. I, I of thought that was it.
I think a lot of us did,
a lot of us did. I know,
I thought that might come back from my
first deployment to Iraq. I was kind of,
you know, I'm thankful that I got
to do this deployment and a thought,
they can't go on that much longer.
But I mean really quickly after we got
back at it spiraled and I said, oh,
this is going to be awhile.
Yeah. Big Time. Um, you know,
while I was on that deployment, I had
got an email from top gun saying, hey,
why don't you come up here next summer?
I mean instructor.
So I came back in May of that deployment
knowing that my next step was going to
go back up to Fallon.
So I was feeling pretty good about that.
I was pretty pumped to know what
was next and um, you know, in that,
that period of time we came back,
you know, I'm packing up that summer,
moving out in the,
in the fall and already the gears are
starting to turn a for what ended up being
our operation Iraqi
Freedom. You know, it's,
the writing is on the wall that this is,
we're not done.
I mean we're really just getting started
and it was several months before that
all kicked off.
I think everybody in the
military certainly knew this
is which way it's going to
happen.
And I think there was some things along
the way that we're supposed to occur,
but we all knew this was
coming. Certainly, you know,
when it kicked off in March
of the following year,
it wasn't a big surprise to any of us.
And I was up at Fallon kind of
watching that whole thing roll.
And I realized that that deployment and
I just finished, it was not the end of,
you know, what, what we're
doing as a country and tried
to deal with this problem.
And, and then you show up at top gun to
be an instructor, which is, you know,
you said the going to top gun was
like a masters. And so now it's,
it's beyond a doctorate, right? I
mean it's, yeah, we say it's the Phd.
I mean in our business, um,
yeah, certainly is a for a
marine or a naval aviator,
a fighter pilot, that's, that's
it. Top gun kind of represents,
that's the school house.
It's the place where you want to be.
And as an instructor you have a,
you have a huge amount of responsibility.
It's a bunch of sort of mid, mid career
guys. It's, it's navy lieutenant,
it's marine corps captains, maybe a junior
major, a junior lieutenant commander.
But it's run by um,
relatively young guys,
guys that have maybe a full deployment
under the belt. And you know,
quickly guys were coming in and having
done Afghanistan combat operations,
guys coming haven't gotten
out of Iraq combat operations.
So in the time that I was there from o
to o five the combat experience on the
staff went from basically
none to everybody.
Every single dude had been in combat.
It was coming off a long deployment where
they had done back to back deployments,
Iraq and Afghanistan guys that I knew had
done 10 month deployments to Iraq on a
carrier. I mean really seasoned guys were
just one generation three years prior.
Not a single person on the staff
had seen any combat like that.
So exact same thing in the seal teams.
We experienced exact same thing and
went from zero or close to zero combat
experiences that it's an odd guy
that had done little operation here,
there to every single guy except
for the new guys, you know,
and then but but your, your learning
curve and when you show back up there,
it was just a steep as the first
time. Yeah, without a doubt.
So when you're there as a student and you
don't understand a lot of what's going
on as a student, at least on
the instructor side, you know,
they're not trying to keep
anything from me, but you're just,
you were so busy just trying
to keep your head above water.
You're not spending a lot
of time wondering what the
instructors are doing in
their free time. Um, you know,
you're just prepping for every brief.
The flight may take an hour,
but you put in 10 hours of work ahead of
time and you debrief for six hours and
when you're done you need to go start
the next prep process again for you.
So you are just all day,
every day thinking about your next
flight and getting ready for that and the
things going on.
So in your learning curve is steep
as a student when you get there.
As an instructor,
and I didn't know this at the time,
you get there when you're
there as an instructor,
you have certainly been selected
to a pretty elite group of folks.
But you don't teach the student at Tompkin
when you're an instructor. For a year.
They spend an entire year
with you as an instructor.
There's only 25 guys on the staff.
And so a third of you basically
if you kind of do the math,
are sequestered for an entire year
just going through what's called,
we call it the Iut,
the instructor under training,
and they're just teaching you
how to teach students. Um,
and in that year you're now flying all
these different training missions with
the instructors that are training you
to be an instructor and you're getting
annihilated again. So that whole
continuum of, wow, I'm pretty good.
Uh, you were reminded very quickly
and so it takes an entire year. Now,
the good news about that is it,
by the time you're finishing your
initial instructor qualification,
you can go teach students.
You have been flying more than you've
ever flown in your entire career. I mean,
I'm fine two, three times a
day, sometimes for a year.
And so you're just getting reps and reps
and reps and you have God more reps,
I think anybody in aviation. So when
the time you get your first student,
you sit down, your very first student
brief, your a game has been elevated,
you know quite a bit and you're able to
fly with the students and teach them way
more effectively. Because when I
finished top gun, I went to Afghanistan,
I didn't do a single air to air mission
for almost a year. I was dropping bombs,
I was doing cast and all
those other types of missions.
So when I got there I was,
I was pretty rusty on those skillsets.
A year of flying with instructors will,
we'll resolve that.
Just it just the amount of flying
that you get, you know, introducing,
we call Matt time, but,
but for a normal pilot,
you're not even getting a fraction of
that, right? A fraction. Yeah. Not only,
you're not getting a fraction of it.
A lot of the time that you're flying is
when you're not at top gun is, you know,
sometimes you do an admin flying
just fine tune from different places.
Sometimes you're just prepping for
a very particular mission. You know,
it takes a skill to,
you know,
the mission is getting ready to drop bombs
or do arm reconnaissance or different
types of flying.
You don't get to see all of it.
You get to see a pretty
narrow amount at top gun.
You get exposed to everything repeatedly.
And so that one against one that we
talked about that we call a BFM basic
fighter maneuvers, which is just you
and another guy fighting two airplanes.
You do that a ton,
but you,
you do all the other things just as
much so you get exposed to the phd.
Part of it isn't just the Reps.
I think that's critical,
but it's that you get exposed to this
nuance part of aviation that you just
didn't even really know existed. So you,
you get all the science, all the math,
all the things that drive us to say this
is why we do the things we do and just
get to practice it over and over. And then
you go back to the science and go, Hey,
I think there's some flaws here
and maybe some differences here.
And the guys at top and into
the one writing the manual,
we literally write a manual,
it's four inches thick of all these
different chapters of how to fly the
airplane.
Everything from doing a one against
wanting to dropping a bomb to mission
planning.
Top Gun owns that.
And so I was given a chapter in a book
and a lecture that I was responsible for
and that the thing that was pretty
amazing for me is when I got there,
the mission set,
that I was responsible for my area,
my subject matter expert area was
surface air threaten counter tactics.
So I was the guy as a captain in the
Marine Corps that was responsible for
writing the chapter,
teaching the lecture and establishing
our tactics for how to defeat threat
surface air missiles and AAA.
And this was from September of 2002 to
march of 2003 that I was the guy that
established the Navy
Marine Corps procedures and
techniques and how we did that
and taught that. So, you know, desert or
I'm sorry, oh I have kicks off, you know,
guys that I'm with had formed with and
train with, are out there on deployments,
are writing me letters. Hey, we're seeing
this threat. What should we do here?
You know, buddies of mine
that I, I've been grown up
in aviation. I'm saying, Hey,
this is what we should do. This is how
you should deal with this particular case.
And so their responsibility as an Ip,
I think why it's such a phd type program
is that your level responsibility grows.
You have to be more than
just a good pilot. I mean,
you can teach anybody to be a good pilot,
but if you can't teach and explain other
guys what they're doing and how to get
better and how to keep themselves alive,
you're kind of useless in combat.
So it was a, it was, it was the
best three years of my life, man.
It was, it was ridiculous. And we just
flew every day, two or three times a day.
I got qualified in the of 16 I got
to fly totally different airplane.
So I was dual qualled in [inaudible]
16 as a marine on a navy base at a navy
command after having done two deployments
on carriers. I mean, you cannot,
it'd be like if I said, Jackie, I
need you to do Jujitsu three day,
three times a day, every day
for three years, and you need,
and that's all I need you to do. I don't
need you to do anything else. Yeah, yeah.
You know, it's, I've actually done a
backseat ride and [inaudible] at Fallon,
as a matter of fact.
And one of the things that I
think is important to understand,
at least from my perspective,
one of the things that made it really
cool was when you get an f 18 if you've
never been in one,
most people,
you're not gonna get the chance to
get an Fha and fly with it. Right.
So I'll give a little description
of what I thought it was.
One of the coolest parts about it is that
if you look at the structure of an fat
tha the,
the pod that you sit in the cockpit is
really far forward and the wings and the
engines are stuff are behind you and
it looks that way when you look at it.
But when you get in it you,
those,
those wings are so far behind you that
you feel like you're in a superhero pot.
You need to turn,
you need to turn hard.
You can't just look back to see the wings
and it's a glass canopy that surrounds
you so you feel like you're just in a
little pod that is moving at whatever,
800 miles an hour and it's,
it's a, it's a crazy feeling.
It's a crazy feeling
and you can cause your,
it's deceiving because you just feel
like you're in this little space pod
somehow.
Star wars powering through the year,
you don't realize that behind you is,
you know,
tons of metal and machinery that's making
this happen and the g forces and all
that stuff. It's a, it's, it's, it's a
very cool, very cool thing to experience.
For me, I thought, oh yeah, that was
awesome. I didn't think to myself, man,
I should have been a pilot. I there's
some, there's some, I know you,
we were talking about it yesterday.
For you,
the connection between man and machine
is a really cool thing that you enjoy.
For me, I don't like it. I don't
like to rely on a machine. Yeah.
I don't even, even getting in Bradleys
and stuff and Ramadi and always think, ah,
you know,
I mean I always was apprehensive about
a big machine that I had to rely on.
I'd want to rely on me and what I could
do and that's why I had that little
disconnect. I'll always, I
still have it today, you know,
that's why I'm waiting for the robot
war cause I want, I'm on a fight,
those things. So I just have a
little disconnect with the machines.
But I can see where people that are,
have that type of mindset.
It's just, you know, it's
just a complete equalizers.
You were telling me last night,
you just like is it's a stock car race.
It's you in the same plane as me
and who is better is going to win,
period. That's it. There's really
no excuses you can make. Yeah,
that's one of my favorite
things is always been to,
one of my favorite things about flying
fighters is that it's, it's an equalizer.
You don't get, you don't bring any
advantage to that airplane. Now,
if we're going to train something, you
and me, there's guys that are bigger,
the guys that are better heart rate,
they got whatever.
There's a whole bunch of ways that
maybe you can bring an advantage. Uh,
you lose all that.
They've been you strap on that airplane
because you're only going to go as fast
as the airplane goes. You don't want to
pull as many Jesus the airplane Poles.
That's what you get now. You get a lot
of all that stuff. I mean it's awesome,
but your success or your failure is 100%
about how well you interact with that
machine and compared to that other guy and
if you lose, you're not. Wow. My engine.
No. Well, I didn't have negative.
You lost because you were
worse than me today period.
And and like you're going to, we're
going to find reasons why, you know,
we record every flight, we record our
radars, we record our information,
our display so we can go back and dissect
and what you end up being able to do
as an instructor is right there. That's
why you lost this decision you made here.
This move.
You went,
you went this direction or we went up
or down and you decided to go at this
speed or whatnot.
You can dissect every single flight and
the great instructors are the ones that
can tell you,
this is why I did this to
you in 45 seconds because
here you made a decision and
it took me this long to capitalize it.
But right now is where I took advantage
of a mistake that you made and you
freeze that may say,
can you put on a TV?
And they see it and they look at it and
that Burns into their brain and then
make that mistake over and over and over
again until eventually they don't make
that mistake. And then you start to
make your money as an instructor.
But being in an airplane,
I brought every bit of capability that
airplane had and I'd never had it.
There's no deal. You don't
start at a disadvantage. Um,
and if you beat somebody,
they have nobody to look at.
No excuse,
no nothing to blame except
for their own performance.
And I loved that and I will always
love that about being a fighter pilot.
Um, and then when you're finding enough
16, now you have a different air points.
So hey, wonder points faster than the
other one. Airplane actually turns better.
And so now instead of it just
being two totally equal platforms,
it's one has particular strengths or
weaknesses that are different than the
other ones.
So you better be really good
about avoiding his strengths
and getting, you know,
and plan to his weaknesses and vice
versa. And if you lose, guess what?
It's still your fault.
100% because instead of you
having two similar airplanes,
you couldn't identify what he was able
to do better than you and his regime that
he has. You know, you're stronger
than me. Fine then I'm going to do,
I'm going to try to be more agile than
you. Uh, you know, you're quicker than me.
Okay, well I'm going to
maybe try to outpower you.
Those type of things and those games that
you play kind of back and forth, you,
there is no question at the end of a
flight at top gun that you're fighting
another dude who won. Nobody comes back.
Like, I wonder how I did on that one.
It's all very evident if you're looking
over your shoulder and the guy is
telling me that he's gunning
you with his airplane,
you don't go back to the debrief
and think, I wonder how that,
I wonder how this is going to play out.
So it's all right there laid out.
The cars are always on the table.
There's a reason for everything.
Why you succeeded in why you failed.
And I just thrived in that environment
because you couldn't hide from anything.
Everybody saw everything. It was all right
there. Who good student, a really good,
talented student coming up to top gun
has what percentage chance of winning.
So if, if the best,
let's say hypothetically,
the best student that I ever saw that
came to talk and as a student from a
squadron,
the best student that ever came to top
gun to fight a qualified TACO instructor
stands at 0% chance of winning.
The best student at top
gun has zero chance.
I could fall asleep in an airplane as
an Ip and a student is not going to beat
me. There is just such a huge, and it
doesn't even mean that we're better.
I don't mean to imply that we were better
pilots, but you just, you at time. Yep.
It's just time. You are just,
it's not, it's, and it's,
and I don't even mean that critical.
It's just not even close.
And nor would they expect it, you
know? I mean, some students may,
every now and then a student kind of
thinks he's going to do some good work.
You know, hey, watch this, I'm awesome,
but most guys show up realizing
that that disparity, I, you know,
I understood that when I
got there as a student,
like these guys are just in a different
world and that you want to get to that
world.
But you know as an Ip
you if I's instructor,
instructor pilot,
yeah.
If I flew my best jet on day
one against the best student,
it would be over so fast that he almost
wouldn't even learn as much as he should.
So you,
you still fly your best airplane but
you make sure that there is a learning
process there. If you want to just
annihilate somebody at top gun, isn't it?
You can do that.
The students that come there
even on their last day aren't,
aren't on your same level. They just
aren't. They've gotten a lot better.
The learning curve is steep,
but when you're in your third
year as an IP at top gun,
you have just had so many reps, you know
so many laps doing the exact same thing.
You've seen everything that, it's almost
like we talked about this yesterday.
It's almost like things are
happening in slow motion for you,
like you're in the Matrix and that guy
is just working as hard as he possibly
can and doing his thing and you're just
kinda sitting there kind of watching it
at like one third speed.
So your ability to decide and do something
to him or something to that airport
or make a decision,
you're just operating at a faster pace
than him and that reaction is just
impossible to keep up with.
I can't wait until you start training
in Jujitsu because you're just going to,
the analogies are just everywhere and
that's one thing I say in Jujitsu.
You can see the future,
you can actually see the future.
When you're training Jujitsu, it's on
someone that doesn't know as much as you,
you know what is going to happen.
You know what they are going to do.
Just like when you're in the cockpit and
you do something and you know what that
person, you know what they're going to
do. You just know it totally. And in,
don't forget to. As a,
as a, as an instructor,
you've been on the receiving
end of that for years as well.
So you understand kind of both
sides of that coin and you know,
you fight with someone and
you'll thank yourself like,
oh I can't believe you just did that.
And then you know,
three turns later is when you get to
take advantage of that because you know,
some time we'll have to play out for his
mistake to really reveal itself. Like,
man, I can't, I can't
believe you just did that.
This is going to cost you over time.
And you can go back on the tape
like I said and said, hey, you know,
you're worried about what happened at
the end, run behind you. But what really,
what let me do that was 30 seconds
ago you did this and when this was the
environment or the circumstances and you
see that stuff and that's when you're
talking about seeing the future. I mean,
if you really want to be a jerk about it,
you know, if guys are
your buddies, you know,
I'll get on the radio like a buddy of
mine off the students that came through,
but you guys are my squash. And I'm like,
oh, that's going to hurt. And I was like,
what? What am I stand by? You know,
and 30 seconds later and
you'll be gun and the guy, um,
because you see the mistakes that they
make and you know how that's gonna play
out. So you are on your own playing
field there as a, as an instructor.
And like I said, man, it's not
about being better or worse,
it's just the time and you get so much
of the time there and you get exposed to
all the,
the why you get the why at top gun.
We teach the why a lot,
but when you're writing the manual,
when you're doing that and you're,
you have all the testing equipment
available and you're running a thousand
computer generated reps to
see what the results are,
the level of what you know about the why
is just so much more. So you just, you,
there's a whole world
available to you to and,
and the guys at top to want to be there
though the most that the ips are killing
to get to a place like that.
So there's not a lot of slackers
they're not allowed to do,
just trying to motivate or kind of prod
along like, hey buddy, let's get going.
You know, dudes are getting after it from
startup to shut down every single day.
And so you're also getting pulled along
cause you want to keep up with your
peers. You know, you don't want to be the
worst top gun instructor there. You know,
every time you think you've made it,
you realize all you did was just getting
a more selective pool and your goal is
the same as to be the
best that you can be.
And hopefully the best you can be is
one of the best guys there. You know,
you'd want to be last to top gun cause
then you're just last and I'm going to be
last in anything who does. And so
that, that's a real kind of a type,
a real aggressive group of dudes and
um, they pull you and, and you, you,
you got to keep up. And
sometimes you know, a couple
of guys here and there don't,
but for the most part the selection
process works pretty well.
You know what score, just to bring
this back for a second too, you know,
talking about leadership and
interacting with other people,
this same exact thing happens when you
start to pay attention to the tactics,
techniques,
procedures of leadership.
You start to see the moves that
people are making. You know,
you start to see the moves that your
subordinate is making because his ego's
flaring up or because he's getting,
um,
taking too much ownership of something
that he doesn't want to let go and he's
getting emotional about it.
Or do you start seeing,
you start seeing the same type
of things at one third speed.
And you know that that was great
for me when I was running the,
the west coast seal team training.
I saw we, we take a platoon,
we had these scenarios and
we put opportune through.
We'd put another platoon through,
we'd put another platoon through it,
we put another platoon through it. We
just over to the same scenario guy here,
good shooter over here, personal on
this hilltop hostage in this room.
We'd put all these guys
through the same scenario.
And so as soon as you'd approach,
as soon as he'd watch them
approach and you say, oh,
the platoon commanders too far in the
rear and this is what's going to happen,
he's not going to see what's coming
up front up. Yep. There it is.
And so you just know
what's going to happen.
And it's the same thing when you start
dealing with their personalities.
You get a guy with a big ego that comes
in and he wants to run everything his
way and he thinks he's gonna
be able to control everything.
And you're looking at, but he's not gonna
be Ale to do this. So you can end up,
and I see that in the business world
obviously now to where you get the same
exact problems of a guy
that's too emotional about
his plan or has too big of an
ego about something.
Or He's not passing the word well enough
or there [inaudible] he's trying to
control everyone and
not using decentralized.
It's so obvious because you have the reps,
we have the reps now in this,
in this arena to be,
to look at a situation and say, okay,
let me watch this. Oh, oh, okay,
I see what's about to happen. Here's
what's going on and we can break it down.
So it's the same thing across the board.
You get that level of just experience
and repetitions and repetitions and now
you can kind of see the future and you
can predict what's going to happen.
And then the good thing
is in the business world,
when you can predict what's
going to happen, you can stop it.
You can get the people on the right track,
pull him back in and get them arranged.
Well,
I think the thing that a lot of people
don't realize it because sometimes I
think it's just different in the military.
The reasons why people are successful in
the military and the reasons why people
fail are exactly the same as why you
succeed in business and why you succeed as
a person or why you failed.
Now look, I know, you know,
being in an airplane is different.
I get that the environment might be
a little bit different being combat,
certainly. So the setting changes in all
these things, the setting is different,
but the reasons are exactly the same. And
so to dispel whatever myths, you know,
it's different in the military.
It's identical in the military that no
doubt it comes out in an airplane or it
comes out on a ship or whatever.
It comes out in downtown Ramadi mean
the setting. Yeah, it's different.
But what's going on? It's
identical. Um, and when you get to,
when you get to be in a place where you
get to devote 100% of your time to that
and you're not distracted by just the
distracts of military bureaucracy and life
of training schedules, and did
everybody do their, uh, you know,
there are annual survey when you're
away from that and you're as living in a
world or just being tactical and doing
nothing but learning about how to be the
best pallet you can be in
the best teacher. Everything,
not just being a fighter pilot.
Everything in the world slows down,
everything slows down. Uh, and I think
it just gives you a perspective on life.
That top gun,
I carry those lessons.
I mean,
obviously I carry that with
me in everything that I do
and I will forever. Right?
You know,
what was honed at a place like that.
And in some ways in the military it's
just a luxury because it's just not that
common to,
for someone to say,
for three years she was going to
do nothing but this like, dude,
are you kidding me?
So,
so speaking of decision making and
good and or bad decision making,
so you're living the dream, living
the dream. You're up in Fallon,
you actually have a house up in
the mountains, you're skin fly in,
everything's good. And, and,
and then somehow you make a decision
that's a little bit off the track a little
bit. What was that all about? I don't know
why she talking about, so yeah, I am a,
I'm in my third year at top gun at 2005,
I was selected to be the training officer.
So I'm running top gun as the senior,
uh, Ip there, which is
just, it's awesome. It's a,
it is literally the, as a
marine, it's a dream job.
You could not ask for anything better.
Uh,
I was dating what ended
up becoming my wife.
So my wife Whitney at the time were
dating, so he lives out there way,
had a place in Tahoe, drove a
corvette. Mike was pretty good man.
And, um, I'm actually coming up
on my end to service obligation.
I can leave the Marine
Corps, uh, in 2005. And I,
I sort of sold my relationship
to Whitney on that idea. Like,
Hey,
come put up with this living and towel,
but I'm going to get out of the
Marine Corps and you don't want,
don't worry about this, none of
that. This is all, it's all come,
don't even worry about that.
And deployments war, it's over.
You don't need to worry about that.
Uh,
and so I think I oversold that to her a
little bit. Got Her to move out to Tahoe.
And so there was just a part of me that
didn't feel done with the Marine Corps.
And ironically in this,
this amazing experience that I had built
up in my mind since I was 16 years old,
I'm now a top gun instructor. I joined
the Marine Corps knowing cause as a,
the [inaudible] was his big influence.
I'm going to leave the Marine
Corps at top gun instructor,
but I had spent four years a flying fat
teen's off carriers were basically in
the, in the navy for the,
for all intensive purposes.
And I was a marine in the marine squad,
but we deployed with navy carriers and
we and I spent three years and fallen on
a navy base with a Navy Command is one
of three pilots on the staff at top gun.
And there was just a part of me
that I knew I was going to be done.
I was ready to leave the Marine Corp
but I wanted to leave the Marine Corps
having fulfilled,
I think that part of being a Marine,
oh real marine is kinda
how I felt. And so, um,
again, uh, I had kind of
contemplating what I was going to do.
You talk to somebody called your monitor,
he's the guy that gives you orders, hey,
this is what's next in your career.
This is where you're going to go for
how long we think you should do this
because it's helpful for whatever the
kind of explains it to you as a guy that
basically is responsible
for your career progression.
And I was kind of going back and forth.
What do I do? Do I stay in, do I get out?
You know, I kind of was struggling
with that decision and he's like, look,
we're going to, you as a top
instructor, you've got a lot of skill,
we get a lot of experience and they want
you to use that and bring it back to
the Marine Corps and go to a squadron and
teach these guys. So he gave me orders.
He says,
your order is going to be to go to Japan,
you're going to fly if [inaudible]
back to the regular fleet squadron and,
and you'll go from there.
And I even,
I think I even got to the point
where I had orders given to me.
Would you have been like a squadron
commander or like an operations officer?
A maintenance officer? I was too junior
and I'd only been in, it was like 10 year,
11 year mark.
So I'm kind of up at what's called,
we call it a department head ramen or
run a major department in a squadron.
It was operations or maintenance or
kind of the two big ones. And um,
I, it just, it just didn't,
it's not what I want it to
do. Um, I hadn't, like I said,
some longterm plans and doing other stuff.
I was thinking long term I was going to
get out and go do something else and so
I called the Monitor. I said,
hey, I want to do a fact tour.
A FAC is that forward air controllers
like you'd just described earlier on the
podcast and we had this a little list on
the Internet that was called a hot fill
list whose basic all the jobs that
nobody wanted and if you called it was a
first come first serve and you
call it volunteer for anything,
you are automatically going to get it.
And because it was just a list of jobs
that they couldn't like force on guys for
whatever reason I'm playing to
explaining it all that well.
But the bottom line is the hot
fill bill. It is, you call you,
it's yours for any reason.
And I'm like, hey man,
I see there's a hot fill to be afforded
air controller in Japan because as we
were going to go to Japan,
we kind of cross that bridge of okay,
we're going to move overseas.
We didn't have any kids with Whitney.
This was with Whitney. She's a little bit
not super cool with it, but we found a,
we'll go to Japan will fly. It will be,
it'll be fine. And he's like, you're not,
you're not going to be a
forward air controller in Japan.
You're going to go fly
and whatnot. I said, dude,
it's right there in black and white man.
It says Hotville I'm your guy.
And he was like, okay. Yeah, I mean he and
so he gave me these orders and I wanted,
I wanted to be a fact because I wanted
to leave the marine corps having
fulfilled all the parts
about being a marine.
And in my mind it's funny cause
it's like we're opposite on that.
The real challenge of the thing
I didn't really want to do,
but I knew I should was getting out of
the airplane and doing something really
hard on the ground.
Like my natural state in the Marine Corps
is in an airplane and for some people
they're miserable. I don't
want to do it. For me that was,
so to do that was to be a forward
air controller was, and it's,
it's strange to hear myself say it.
I didn't want to go be a
forward air controller,
but I knew I needed to go do that.
There's no,
I needed to leave the Marine Corp
and say, yeah, I did that too.
And it was just a matter
I think of fulfillment of
kind of an exclamation point
on a career that I
always kind of fantasize.
And as I learned more
about the marine corps,
there was more to it than just being a
pilot. Right. So I just wanted that. So,
so in your mind, were you thinking
forward air controller in Japan met,
you're going to go over there, you
know, have a little team of marines.
You'd go out to the different
training ranges, call for
some bombs, all good. You,
you know, go home at night, be
with your wife, might even go,
I'm in Japan just in just a nice
little sort of like a long vacation,
working a little bit of time on the
ground. I get to go to the field.
I spend the night in the woods, you're
smelling something like that, you know,
it really cool camping and they pay for
it. Yeah. So yeah, that's what it was.
I was going to go to Japan.
There's a bunch of really cool,
it was going to be an oak and how
actually so not mainland Japan.
Okinawa has got great scuba diving
and it's Kinda neat and you know,
I could bring my wife with me.
It was gonna be a lot of fun and you can,
I can train. I was going to teach guys
how to use airplanes to drop bombs.
I knew how to do that.
I was going to be a really cool thing.
So I get these orders and my
wife and I moved out to Japan.
We got there and uh,
to Okinawa,
a place called camp pants and a little
base up there in the middle of the island.
And I'm there probably,
dude, I'm probably there a week and my
boss, the brigade platoon commanders like,
Hey your, we're going to send a brigade
platoon, which is probably 50 guys,
I'm guessing,
I'm guessing at the numbers to Camp
Lajune because of that angle go.
Just came back from seven months in
Iraq and they need to go right back and
turned very quick turnaround or they
don't have enough qualified guys. And so,
I mean, I'm there a week and I'm
coming home until Whitney like, hey,
here's the deal.
They need guys to go out to Laguna to
do this deployment to Iraq and I'm going
to be one of those guys. So we were there
instead of a year we were there for,
maybe she's like,
is there snorkeling
because you were telling
me about scuba diving.
So we crammed a year's worth of stuff
and about six weeks, because we had,
so it was probably maybe early November,
uh,
when the word kind of came down and we
knew that we had till the end of the
calendar year.
So we shoved a year's worth of living in,
in Japan in about six weeks.
And when we did Korea,
we did Thailand who did mainland in Tokyo.
We did got her dad called,
I mean we did it all, only December
22nd or whatever it was, you know,
we flew home and I went straight to the
lagoon from there to start training with
second Anglico,
uh,
which was the team that had just come
back from Iraq after their seven month
deployment on a very quick turn,
there are probably four
months into their turnaround.
So just real quick for people
that don't know what Anglico is,
the Anglico Anglico stands for
air naval gunfire liaison company.
And really what it is is it's a group
of, it's a, it's a group of small teams,
four or five man teams called fire power
control teams. And what those teams,
we're all supposed to be able
to do is control airplanes,
tell airplanes what to do with their
bombs. Uh, we could control artillery.
So how to fire artillery ordinance and
even we didn't do it there and Iraq,
but we could use naval gunfire.
So guns off ships,
we were training all three of those skill
sets and the whole point of an angle
go and a place like Iraq is,
it's, you had different units.
He had no navy units, army
units, Marine Corps units,
and as an angle go your liaison. So that's
what the l and angle go is. So I could,
I was trained to go to an army
unit and know how army does,
people may not know this,
all of the servers is actually
do the same job differently.
So the army and the Marine Corps will
get the same mission and have a totally
different way of doing it cause their
doctrine or their training is different.
Now it's similar but there's a bunch of
pretty critical differences in there.
And so what we're trying to do is we had
all marine airplanes in where we were
in Iraq and all army land forces and so
the army doesn't have any training in
how to use Marine Corps.
Airpoints Marine Corp does have a lot
of training to use army ground forces.
So when those two people connect,
there's,
there's a problem with how
they communicate. And what
they want from each other.
Insert Anglico. We're the liaison between
the army ground units and in this case,
the Marine Corps air units.
So my job was to control marine airplanes
to support the army on the ground.
And that was all over Iraq.
And what the Anglico team would take this
whole group and break it into maybe 25,
four man teams and when all of the
country to go do this same mission with a
whole bunch of different units.
And so that was our mission
as a forward air controller.
And I was qualified as a forward air
controller because I had flown airplanes,
drop bombs and combat,
understood how fat is.
We're supposed to support ground maneuver.
And I went to school for air controllers.
Cool.
So let's go to Japan will be fun or
pretend to do that for a year. Um,
and then we end up in Campbell,
the June training to go to Iraq.
And now it's your first time
kind of doing grunt work. Right?
So last time I had held a rifle,
shot a rifle and worn a pair of
combat boots was the basic school.
So I had, um, you know, I
was, I got my air slot at,
at TBS. That was a big day for me. Uh,
you know, I'd done six months of that.
I've had that check in the block.
I was feeling pretty good
about that and I had never,
I don't think I put on my
Kamia my camouflage uniform.
I think I wear a flight suit.
Honestly.
I think everyday for seven years I
could probably count on one hand,
well even longer than that,
I wasn't even counting flight school.
I could probably count on one hand the
number of days that I didn't wear a
flight suit from the time that I selected
to go to flight school to the time
that I ended up at Anglico days.
I mean, so this was a foreign,
now I had,
I was a marine,
I went through the basic school was all
back there somewhere. Um, but you know,
I think there is this, and I've
mentioned this, I think to you,
I think it's a sort of this habit
of self sabotage. Like, well,
I can't leave the Marine Corp.
That being a, being a real marine.
So I'm going to literally sabotaging
myself by volunteering for a job that I
don't know if I really want to do,
but now I'm stuck doing it.
So I'm going to have to do that. So I
won't ever have to say I didn't do that.
So this kind of cycle of
break promises to my wife, uh,
volunteering for stuff I didn't really
want to do but knew that I should.
And next thing you know, it all blew up
in my face cause I, let's go to Japan.
Japan's awesome,
good Sushi and great experience there
and it's gonna be awesome and I will be a
fact and I can for the rest of my life,
say,
well was a royal marine that was a
fact and I did all that. And you know,
it's January and Campbell
shuffle look. Yeah, there's four.
So yeah, make no mistake. I mean,
I, I did that, I volunteered,
but I did not at the time when I was
trading in my flying orders for these Faq
orders.
I didn't expect to be in Ramadi but as,
hey, we need to send a brigade platoon
to uh, Campbell's unit prep those guys.
Of course. Yep. I'm going, I
mean I'm not going to not go.
That's what we need to do.
We're going to go do that.
When I got to Campbell as you and I
ended up being the senior just by rank,
the senior f a forward air
controller in the unit,
I was kind of a mid level major,
um, you know, come from top gun.
I came straight from talking to that
and I was experienced guy and the
commanding officer,
no joke.
I can picture the day walks in one day
and he hands me a piece of paper and it's
got like 26 lines on it.
One for every team.
And on the other sheet was all the
locations that we were going to go to and
he's like,
fill out where all the teams are going.
Cause we've got to cover these
15 different locations, you know,
one to two teams per location and just
write the number of the team on there and
get this back to me by close of business.
Like Roger that sir, I take care of it.
And
again, my wife loves the story
and I didn't tell her at the time,
but my best friend who I grew up
with was in Ramadi at the time.
He was in third battalion,
seventh Marines who we replaced when we
got out there or we did a turnover with.
And
that's where the war was. Man. I mean in,
in late 2005 and early 2006
the world was in Ramadi.
And so I took the pen,
I wrote lightening six and so six one six,
two and six three we're all going Ramadi.
And I handed it off to ever filled
it out, gave to the CEO. And so,
mmm.
If you're going to go do something
you don't necessarily want to do,
but you're going to go do it,
you might as well do it.
And that's where the war was.
I could have gone to a whole host of
other places where there's not much going
on.
It would have been relatively chill.
I would've gotten that check in the
block for sure. I would have said, yeah,
I went to here or there and Nope, no hit
on the guys who were different places.
It just, it was just more going on
there. Um, and if I wasn't gonna go,
then somebody else is going to go do that.
Was Neil Neil was telling you what was
up. He said, hey, it's on big time. No,
he and I were tight and
we talked as regular as we
could, as much as we can say.
Was He telling you like,
Oh yeah,
I was putting rounds over shooting
yesterday and you said, well,
what were you shooting out? And
he's like, people, yeah, I was just,
it was such a foreign thing to me as
a pilot. Certainly coming from top,
this is my best friend too.
And our whole life we both wanted
to be a marine pilots and we, we,
we never were in the same unit together.
We just couldn't get aligned with that.
It never occurred to me when we were
kids dreaming about being a Marine Corps
fighter pilots at the only time we'd
ever served together was in Ramadi as
forward air controllers. I,
he'll listen to this podcast,
he'll get a good chuckle out of this.
But,
so he was there for the seven months
prior. So I think the something, you know,
maybe June or July of that year when
I was getting ready to get orders,
he was on his factor and he was
just a battalion back in three,
seven Oh p two nine three will be herea
oppa just doing the deed, man. I mean,
getting after. Yeah,
big time and struggling.
We know there's a lot going on there.
And when he would tell me these stories,
even someone who had been a marine
for that long, he's like, yeah,
we're in a firefight. And I'm like, are
you shooting a rifle? Is like, yeah man,
I get what it's like the people that are
shooting at me. It just, it, it, it's,
you're disconnected and you have this,
you don't have the sense
of what that means.
And so even as I was processing what he
was saying and trying to understand and
then saying, this is where the,
this is what I'm going to go do,
kind of volunteering to go do that.
I'll be honest with you,
there's still a part in retrospect that
didn't really quite fully grasp what
that meant. I don't know how anybody
on the first deployment to a place,
like Ramadi goes into that. You know, I
dabbled aviation. You're like you said,
I'm up in the sky. I mean,
it's relatively safe. Uh,
and I'm sure even the first
appointment you did, there's just,
there's an element of just not
being able to fully understand it.
And that didn't even become clear to me
until right when we're getting ready to
leave from Adi and the new units coming
in and I was explaining what they're
meant to get into.
That's when it really hit me.
And I just remind myself a year earlier,
I'm like,
I'm that dude that really doesn't know
what the hell is about to happen to him
and what's about to go on.
But it was like I said, man,
I don't even want it to make it
sound like that big of a deal.
But I volunteer for a fact to her.
They need to guys to go to London to
go to Iraq. That's where reminders,
where the fight was my best friend
who was there. I'm going to Ramadi.
And that was about it. It was just,
that's where I thought I should do.
So I went to [inaudible] and now
you're leading marines too. Yeah.
And yes. So I, I,
I explained just a minute ago about
those things that make you successful and
things that,
that lead to failure are identical.
They are the exact same things in an
airplane or the same on the ground,
but the environment is different.
It is different.
There's no way around it. And I also
would say to that, and for good reason,
I think the ground marines,
you know,
I worked with a lot of
infantry and artillery.
Most of Anglico was made up of artillery
and some infantry not, and you know,
obviously there's pilots
that are controllers.
There's a decent bit of skepticism
of pilots coming in to lead these,
these teams. And I think for good reason,
you know, because a lot of these guys,
when I talked about combat experience,
they're on their third fourth deployment
to Iraq. Totally man. You're coming in.
Yep, they're on there.
They've already done,
you're wearing your top gun patch on
your shoulder and your kidneys. Well,
what's worse is I'm not wearing my
top gun patch, I'm wearing my cammies.
And they're like, have you ever wash those
cameras? I'm like, as a matter of fact,
I haven't, they're fresh, you know,
brand new and they're
wearing their cammies from,
they did the march up to Baghdad.
They went home for four months
in second wrap back around.
And did Oyu have two guys
that did full allusion?
They're back and they're on their
third appointment in three years.
And they're legit deployments.
And you know, Dave Burke,
Mr Top gun shows up and is like, hey,
where's this brigade platoon? You know,
where's my salt team? You know?
And I think that skepticism of
for good reason is who is this guy?
And that's a real,
that was a real leadership challenge
for me is to apply those things,
things that I knew or they were effective,
but in an environment that I'm
totally out of my comfort zone, man.
I'm totally out of my comfort zone and I
have to apply a skillset of things that
I just haven't,
I haven't shot a rifle since 1994.
I got to the basic school in October 94.
The first thing you do
is go to the rifle range.
There's the last time I squeeze the
trigger on a rifle was October of 1994 and
here it is is, you know, January
of 2006 prepping to go to Ramadi.
And I've got a site in my m four,
so they should be skeptical a little bit.
And, um, it was a challenge for me,
a real leadership challenge of to be
successful in a place that I'm not
comfortable with.
To be honest with you.
If you told me I was going
to lead a squadron in combat,
I'd feel pretty comfortable doing that.
I know it'd be a challenge. It'd be hard,
but I wouldn't feel like I don't know
about this. I would be all over it.
I don't mean to say easy, but right in
my wheelhouse, not, not true for that.
And so, um, I worked hard to try to
be successful in that. And you know,
you gotta get your Marines
to buy off on your program,
you know that because you're going to
go downtown with those guys, you know?
And every relationship with anyone of
those guys was different as you know,
when you've got to build
those relationships and
demonstrate that, you know,
this is gonna work. And then, you know,
just talk a little bit about your people
have heard about what to you bruiser
was doing over in Ramadi and
we'll get to how we interacted.
But overall, oh, you guys
doing, when you first got there,
you just kind of jumped into it.
We can feed as they say we did man.
Um,
so I get there.
I've got assault team that stands for
supporting arms liaison team. It really,
what it meant was three of
those little Forman teams, uh,
grouped together in a one 13 man team
cause we had an additional corpsman,
little, uh, medic with us.
So I had three of those teams that I was
responsible for and I kind of knew what
I expected was going to happen.
I got there that I would be
in what's called the Toc,
the tactical operations center,
which was,
I'd kind of run things from the desk
and it's farm out my teams and units to
support the guys that needed our help,
these army units or we're
going to go do missions.
They needed someone to help them
control the air. I had those teams,
I would give them those teams.
Well it took basically no time to get
there and realize that the demand signal
for our support was higher than
we could have ever responded to.
They needed 20 of our teams,
not three.
And so that idea that I
would kind of be a coc guy,
a top guy was over in the first day
because as I get there and we're going to
the turnover with the other Anglico
team getting ready to leave,
he's introducing me to all the
people he had been working with.
And it's like 15 different teams,
you know,
they're not running operations
with like three battalions,
it's 40 squats,
you know,
and these guys are going out in 1213 man
teams and they all need you. Yup. So,
and there's operations I've been,
just so everyone knows,
there's 5,600 people in the one one
80 or you showed up with two, two,
two to 6,000 people or
whatever. And there's operations
going on all over Ramadi,
every single micros,
people patrolling.
There's people getting in
firefights every single night.
There's constant gunfire.
And so there's no way with three
teams you're going to cover all that.
You can't do it. Yeah. And that was sort
of the immediate awareness for me is
not only was I not going to
be able to support everything,
I know how to prioritize and tell folks,
hey,
we can do this and not that
I can you here or there.
And so very quickly it was a matter of
how am I going to break down my team and
support these guys.
Um,
I did have an advantage
that I was as an fat pilot.
That was the primary aircraft,
Faa teens in Harrods or the primary
aircraft that was doing the support.
And I knew those airplanes really well
and I was able to very quickly when I saw
what the army,
hey,
we're doing this patrol today and we're
going to take our humvees from the camp
Remati to go to this location.
And it would be really
difficult just to get there.
Just navigating at night in your Humvees
on the night vision goggles and the
roads can be kind of confusing and
you know what it's like down there.
And some days you're operating in
downtown Ramadi and it's straight up urban
combat, like just buildings and five
miles away. You can be in a place,
we call it Mike, Charlie one that
it looks like Vietnam. I mean it's,
it's the contrast if for
being so close together,
it was so incredible how
different those places were.
And so every environment was different.
I was able to understand how,
what airplanes could do well and
not well in those environments.
And so as they asked for support, I'm
like, Hey, I can't really do that,
but what I can do is this,
and maybe this would be more helpful
for you and I can very quickly build a
relationship with the army,
which is really who you needed to
be the best support for the marines.
They were going to get on board.
We're good. We had a relationship.
I wasn't worried about my
marines and US building our team.
What I was worried about was us as a team,
being effective for the folks that were
supporting and showing that we could do
good work for those guys. And we
took a very different approach. Uh,
I immediately broke our team into three
separate teams. Six one, six, two and six.
Three I actually sent the six three team,
a guy named Alan to
another base blue diamond.
You remember that base right across the
river because there was a company based
out of blue diamond that we're
doing operations independently.
They never had any ANGLICO support,
so I do, do you gotta go move?
They literally moved there and lived
with those guys and then my other teams,
six one or six to Adam and I just,
we took a whiteboard and all the
requests for support and we just started
plugging in her names in and so it was
just, I had five guys. He had four.
He had his own Humvee. I had
my own Humvee. We had all
the weapons, all the radios,
and just started to just go do operations.
Two to eight.
We'll do everything for just a little
vehicle patrol where they're just do a
president patrol there,
two Humvees driving around the city.
We would just jump in on that
and just bring a third truck,
which was a ton of
firepower and awareness.
Sometimes we're just doing foot patrols
and we would just go walk around and do
move into contact or do room
clearing, stuff like that. Jocko, man,
I found myself way,
way out of my comfort zone very early.
I think my second mission there was a
raid where I was ended up like clearing a
room.
I was in a stack of dudes clearing
a room while I was trying to talk to
airplanes overhead of were and it was
just a basically a manpower shortage.
It's like, yeah, you can get in. Yeah, go.
You and these two guys go clean the room.
I don't mean Roger that, you know, um, and
I was a senior or mid grade majors are,
I was always kind one of the senior guys,
but I wasn't in charge of this.
So I'll be working for a first lieutenant,
which was perfectly fine.
It was his platoon. He was doing this
mission. He knew what he was doing.
I was there to support as best
as I could that image of like,
y'all just get up on the roof and
control air. It'll be awesome.
What do you need me to blow up?
Negative. I mean it was, hey,
get in line and start getting after it.
And I think that,
I remember that second mission,
we're with the two to eight and the
lieutenant was, I think he was like, uh,
I think he worked at
home depot. No, Jessica.
Cause there was a national guard
unit and national guardian.
These dudes were awesome. He's been
there for probably 10 or 11 months.
By the time I got there,
maybe even longer,
they'd been there almost a year hardened
dudes that had lost a lot of guys and
sacrifice a ton.
But I was learning everything I could
from them because they were veterans and I
was brand new. I was supposed
to bring this great capability,
but the reality was I was just soaking
up from them as much as I could.
And I'm clearing a room with this guy,
you know,
so the phrase of what am I doing
here? Oh, uh, went through my head.
I'll watt a while. I was there
and it was just Kinda, it.
Ramadi was a type of place that the
deal was, is that when you got there,
it was just a bullet train and you
just jumped on the train or you had to,
you couldn't slow things down
and you certainly couldn't
ask. There's other guys,
hey, can we, can we dial it back a
little bit? We need to get up to speed.
They were just doing their thing and if
you are going to be anything other than
a hindrance that you need
to get on board immediately.
And so that's what we
did as best we could. Um,
and I have a lot to thank for the guys
at [inaudible] because no matter how hard
we tried those first couple
of times, we're, we're just
getting up to speed. We're,
we're not, uh, you know,
bringing our a game yet we're,
we're trying to figure out
what's going on around us.
And there's no doubt that without
those guys, their leadership,
their willingness to kind of bring
us on board and get us up to speed,
that played a big part. We got up to
speed quickly, but they, one I'm sure,
you know,
we were struggling to kill us.
Like we were talking about with flying
and Jujitsu and fighting everything else.
You show up there and things are going,
they're not slowed down a third,
they're going five times faster
and you're just seeing, you know,
you're getting told to clear a room.
That's the only thing in the world you
can see is now this room and you're not
aware of all this other
stuff that's going on.
And it definitely takes
some ops to get your,
get your senses about you of what's
happening. Yeah. And the ops were,
there were so many different kinds
of operations. Like I said, you know,
you'd go from doing just um, you know, uh,
three Humvee presence patrol in
downtown Ramadi is not cool. It's not,
it's just you're just waiting
for something to go wrong.
Whether it's getting lit up, you know, in
a firefight, RPGs getting shot. I mean,
you are literally just driving around
waiting for somebody to do something to
you. You know, these presence patrols
and then you go right from that too.
You get some intelligence that somebody
needed to grab was in a, you know,
a house somewhere in a totally different
environment and you'd be off doing a
raid. We help stand up the QRF.
You've talked about that in the past,
that quick reaction force
where you literally just
waited right outside the gate
of the main base for somebody to call
for help. Okay, something's gone wrong.
It's here.
Come help us.
And so we just started doing
all these missions and I,
I just was on board with
all of them and they very,
they were very different from day to day.
And you got to call for fire to do,
you legit. We did. And we, we,
between me, I did a lot and my team's,
we,
I controlled the release of every single
piece of ordinance in the Marine Corps.
Hammetry uh, Marine Corps inventory.
So every piece of ordinance that the,
the airport, the Hornets and Harriers
dropped and everything from the hood,
he was in the cobras and artillery. We
called artillery as well. They had a,
you know,
a field artillery battalion out there
that we did controls from as Anglico I did
myself. So you know that store,
you know what you get to TBS,
there's an old saying in the Marine Corps,
we all subscribe to it.
Every marine is a rifleman and
we are a top gun instructor.
That could not be further from the truth
because the last thing you are as a top
gun as the training officer at top
gun skiing in Lake Tahoe on a Saturday
afternoon is a rifleman. But
I will, I will say this, uh,
for the Marine Corps. Yeah,
I'm biased. I'm a little parochial to
the Marine Corps dude. It's all in there.
The ocs, TBS, all that exposure, all
that doctrine, everything that you learn,
it's there now. It took a while to dig
down and find it and those same things.
When I went to ocs and I was the
skinniest guy there and I was scared,
I couldn't get through it. I'm like,
wait a second, bigger, tougher,
stronger dudes are doing this or not
doing this. And I am, it's all in there.
And so I just had to figure out how to
tap that stuff again and bring it back up
and just go do it.
So
great decision near I am in Ramadi getting
after it. And then you guys showed up.
Yeah,
there was one story you were telling me
that you were calling to fire up and mc
one and it was your buddy.
Oh yeah. Yeah. We are doing,
um, we're doing what's called movement to
contact my favorite mission as a pilot.
Nothing better than movement
to contact and a movement,
conduct mission as you literally, you
drive your Humvees, take all your,
your folks out and you set up a staging
area in the north side of this, uh,
this big areas,
big kind of wooded dirt has like little
ravines and trees and stuff like that.
And we would just, we would walk
a patrol, I mean you'll have 10,
15 guys or just go from north to south
and the mission was called move into
contact.
So you walked until you got in contact,
which meant you got into a firefight.
And I remember, not the same day,
but my first day going there, I think
it was Bravo company at two to eight.
I could be wrong,
but I'm pretty sure it was.
And I met the platoon commander for the
first time and I kind of get out of my
Humvee. I walk up, I'm, I'm looking
for the pertinent commander,
I'm there as a supporting asset.
I'm a helpful guy cause I bring
airplanes is going to be good for them.
And he walks up and he's got
a shotgun hanging on his,
on his kit and you know, I was
a brand new guy, but I, you
know, I was, I'm like, hey,
hey, what's with the shotgun? You know,
I have a rifle and he's got a rifle.
He goes, hey, demands with,
I found that this is the best
weapon for these type of missions.
And it turns out he actually was
right on that patrol. Like, dude,
what am I doing here, man has, you
know, I want to go do a foot patrol,
the guy with a shotgun. Um,
so I knew that I was in,
there's a lot in store for that. Um,
and we would do these patrols, these,
these move into contacts and you'd end up
in a building. And my job as a fac was,
hey, get out in the building, get
up on top of the roof right away.
And I would do Overwatch,
you know, similar, different
assets. I had airplanes,
I had radios, seals, or
do Overwatch all the time.
And it's just a matter of cover and moves.
I would get up on the roof and go, hey,
this is what I see. This is
what the airplane sees. Okay.
You guys jumped to that next building.
Sometimes the next building
would be 20 yards away,
sometimes it be 200 yards away.
So you were,
you would just do these bounding
movements, building to building.
And then when they get
to the next building,
my other guy would be up in the roof.
He said,
you're going to run down and
go to the next building. Um,
and so we get into this building and as
soon as I get up on top of the roof of
the building,
so if you can picture it,
half of us are in the
roof of the building,
half of the other guys are trying
to move to the other building.
So they're out in the open and from that
other building as I get up on the roof
that I looked up and the first thing
that happens is like three RPGs hit the
building that I'm in
directly underneath me,
probably probably miss our
team by like 15 feet below us.
So above their heads and below us.
That's the first thing that happens.
And there was a vehicle,
like a truck and I was a car is like just
some car in between on a let kind of a
dirt road behind some trees where this
fire came from and we had airplanes
overhead. It was too fat and
ds. I remember it, um, from
a, uh, an east coast, uh,
Squadron. And, um, you know,
at TBS they teach you, hey,
every marine is a rifleman and they still,
they tell you these stories is that one
day you're going to be in a position
where you're going to be in a firefight
and there's going to be an airplane
overhead and it's going to be a buddy of
yours from TBS going to your old buddy
and you're going to be like, hey, Jocko,
which Dave helped me out and Dave's gonna
roll in on his white horse and come up
with his horn it and
blast these things out.
And your infantry buddy's
going to thank you.
One day I'm going to write on Ron was
that I was on the ground and the guy
flying the airplane was one of my
closest friends, a guy named, uh,
Bu Friedman was the
opposite of the squash.
And I just left and no joke.
I'm like,
Hey, weren't, we're were UN
troops in contact. You know,
we're taking fire from wherever.
And on the radio he says, hey chip,
it's Bu what do you knew?
And it took me right back to TBS and one
the problem was I was supposed to be in
an airplane when that happened.
And I'm like, I said, uh,
I said south to north
call wings level and, and,
and that's what happened.
And I got four passes from these fat ins,
did these strafing runs on this car.
And I remember looking at the, uh,
the army guys with us under
the first lieutenant and I
looked at him, I go, dude,
we're going to be fine. That's like
super cool. Like very chill. Hey,
this just happened.
I see what's going on.
There's Hornets overhead had saw
everything. What do you need? I need this.
We're in the next call is wings level.
Hey, you're cleared hot and you know,
the hair on my arms standing
up telling the story.
It's just one of those stories
where the Marine Corps,
for whatever insane reason,
we'll take fat and pallets and train
them millions of dollars in 10 years of,
of training them and they'll stick
them on the ground. And it's for
that exact reason that that exact event
was I could bring an asset that the army
would never have an environment that
they would never be able to use.
And through two buddies just talking
point English to each other on the radio,
make it happen in like that.
And um,
I was supposed to be
in that airplane Jocko,
that's how it was supposed to work out.
But in that particular day, a man, it was,
the roles were reversed, but
it was, it was an awesome,
it was kind of a culmination of a lot
of things like that. The Marine Corps,
it's a legit, that thing they
breed in us. It's a real thing. Uh,
and it was pretty satisfying
to be honest with you.
We see that core burn in the ground
and then eventually, I don't know,
maybe a month or so goes by and we show
up. And who's the first, who did you meet?
First Life? Yup. Lafe uh,
was the first guy that I met.
Um, actually Lafe and Tony. All
right. Show up together. Um,
so we had seen you guys,
you know,
W W we had turn over and we were
just kind of getting up to speed.
We've probably been there maybe a month
or so before you guys had, so you know,
a quick learning curve ward just
kind of getting comfortable, uh,
with what's going on. And we also,
there's a new brigade platoon coming in,
I'm sorry, a new um, uh, uh,
armored division coming into,
we know that the unit that were there,
the two to eight,
that brigade combat team is leaving.
We knew new brigade combat team is
coming in and we were actually in just a
relatively short period of time.
We're kind of the continuity because
all the old guys are leaving.
We Ha we had the overlap.
So we had to kind of a prominent role
with the new battalion and the new
battalion commander. He's retired now. Um,
awesome dude from a one three, seven arm,
a guy named Tedesco. Just an awesome,
awesome. Just an awesome
dude. Awesome. Um,
he had been there as part of its turnover,
had come out a couple of months prior,
maybe a month prior. And saw us and we
had, my favorite thing about Tabasco is,
like I said, awesome guy. We,
we were getting ready to do
a big operation with them.
I think it was the first time we were
pushing them to south central Ramadi and
we were in his briefing
and he's quoting pat,
but he's quoting pattern the movie. He's
just kidding. After I was like, yes,
yes.
Thank you.
Thank you for bringing me here this day
that he was awesome and he had seen me,
he just so happened when he was doing
his initial turnover before the, the,
the battalion came out. I had
done, I controlled, uh, uh, um,
a release. I controlled a hell
fire and blew up a car. Uh,
and he got to see it and it was kind of a
cool thing as he come, he was like, who,
you know who these guys, right? I'm
in the middle of doing a real control.
Happened to be in the COC that day.
Blow up a car.
It's all in the video would get this
big TV screens that show the whole thing
and this card detonates and cool
pictures and everything. And he,
he comes over to me after we're done,
I'm kind of sitting there and he's a
lieutenant colonel and the major in Sir.
And he's like, can you do that when
we get here? I'm like, absolutely man.
He's like,
we're going to get along great.
That was my initial rate interact
with him. So it was awesome.
And so we knew when they were coming back,
we had already just to
virtue of that experience,
built in pretty good inroads with them
and we're going to do some good work.
He was also the type of guy, but there's
this whole brigade team came in that's
5,000 guys, but his battalion,
that group of, you know,
several hundred was really the core group
that I initially did most of my work
with. And his approach was, if you
can help us, you're on the team. Yeah.
There, um, same exact attitude he had with
us. Yeah. For sure. For all the enablers.
So, uh, they were called the bandits
and they had a little band at Penn.
I had kind of a skull and crossbones kind
of thing. You are, if you, you were a,
I was a bandit Tisher just totally onboard
the team and he treated us like his
own guys and that was awesome.
And so, um, all the enablers,
we had military, we had working dogs,
we had explosive ordinance disposal,
we had Anglico folks.
We have the seals in all these different
groups from different places that none
of them were assigned to him.
But his approach was,
if you can help my soldiers out, you're
on your abandoned, you're on the team.
And everyone was like, right
on, let's do this. Cause that's,
you needed to work with them anyway,
you might as well make the best of it.
We started to do a couple of missions
and every one of those missions was your
teams and my teams. Uh, and
I would say probably in the
first week or so, you know,
I'm guessing a little bit of dates,
but relatively quick.
And the first couple of missions
we are doing the similar things.
We're bringing support and Overwatch
and helping these guys do their job,
which is the exact same thing
you guys were doing, you know,
totally different ways. But ultimately
we're supporting these guys. I'm in my,
my little building there one day,
whatever,
just sitting around prepping for
something and in walks Lafe and Tony,
you know, he joined, they drove over from
your base, which is kind of, you know,
a little bit of a haul around the, around
that are driving. And he goes, hey man,
um,
loved to work in the morning.
We find a way that we can work together
and some of these missions and we got
this big mission coming up. You want to
come down and, and brief with us. Well,
yeah, absolutely. I'd love to go
brief with the seals. It'd be awesome.
I thought it would just be the
kind of cool one time thing.
I get to see how seals do
business. Um, and that was it.
That was his introduction had life.
And Tony, I'll be really candid. I,
I'd like to think I would have done that.
I doubt I would've gone to chark based
and knocked on your door and said,
hey Lafe Jukka let's
do some work together.
He made that initial contact and him and
Tony were definitely equal opportunity
employers. We at the same thing
as, you know, Colonel Tabasco.
If we thought someone could do something
to help us out or we could compliment
each other in any way, man,
we were knocking on doors
to try and make that happen.
For sure. Yeah. And that was
his approach. Um, I didn't,
I had never done any work on the ground.
I didn't know much about the seals.
I'll be very blunt.
I had my own opinion of what I
assumed you guys would be like.
And it was probably something
out of the movies I expected,
like long beards and do just running
around doing their own thing. Uh,
and so I was actually a little surprised
that that life came and asked to do
some work with us. And so I, I went
to that first night and mission, uh,
that first brief,
I don't want to say I was skeptical,
but I was certainly interested in what,
because my fear was that you guys
are going to go do your own thing.
And my guys were kind of just
either not be able to keep up,
not know what you're doing and not fit
in very well and be able to help out and
just kind of put ourselves at risk.
And
look, I'll, I'll say this very bluntly,
I have a very high bar when you leave
top gun on what to expect from a mission
brief and mission execution
and mission debrief.
Cause that's what we're all about.
And I was pretty sure that there's no
chance that you're going to do anything
anywhere near that.
And I was shocked and kind of overwhelmed
at how professional your organization,
your team was.
And that was the biggest thing for me
was what are these guys going to be like?
I just sort of pictured
a kind of a pickup game.
It was go there and just kill some bad
guys and come on back and high five each
other. And Dude, it was one of the most
professional organized mission briefs.
I totally understood what your plan was.
I knew exactly where I was going
to fit in. We went and did it.
And then you guys debriefed
after we came back after this.
It was a relative uninvent nothing really
happened that night. And in terms of,
in the grand scheme of things that we saw,
we were there and then you debriefed it,
you guys came back and you mission
debrief dudes were there kind of clean and
weapons and tea and going through
and analyzing what happened.
And that was it man. I was
totally on board. I was, I was,
I was sold at that. We could work
together like pretty effectively. Um,
and that was kind of the beginning.
It just sort of started out of the blue
and you guys came down and asked to do
some good work and, and we did.
You've done a lot of work and it did.
Your team did a lot of work with us
cause we, we started to think cause,
cause for our, from our perspective,
and I know, you know, there's one,
a junior officer out there who's now
probably a lieutenant commander or maybe
even a commander at this point.
But at that time, you know,
he was on his first appointment
and he was a [inaudible].
What we call in the seal teams are air
controllers are called the Jay Tac.
And so here he is and some of those
missions, instead of being a seal,
he's been a j tech. So he's one
of those guys that looked over it,
you guys and said,
hey wait a second,
can you take this radio for me and do
that thing so I can go do my frogman stuff
over here. And that ad and
plus, again, to be blunt,
you guys could do it a lot better than we
could, period. You know, we, we, you know,
you were an f 18 pilot for crying
out loud and we had a new guy,
junior officer on the radio
trying to call for fire.
You guys were just imminently better
qualified to do it. And so yeah,
we looked at it as if,
okay we that gives us one more shooter
and it gives us a whole new level of
expertise.
Now of course there's Jay tax and the
seal teams that they are a lot more
experience and they're
awesome and of course,
but in our group to bring you guys was
just a huge level up for us to get a lot
better and give us more people to
maneuver as seals on assaults are on
Overwatch's or whatever.
So it turned out to be a real
good little little relationship.
You've got to go in there.
It was a classic when, when
when a, when a seal says,
Hey, would you control the air so
I can go shoot people, you know?
And that means I'm no,
I don't have to clear that room and be
in a position where I might have to do
something like that. I'm all over it and
I, yeah, I know who you're talking about.
We had,
he and I had a great relationship,
someone that I really loved working
with who wanted to go be a frog man.
Like you said, I want it to go
control of her plants and uh,
we found a way to make that
stuff work now. It was,
it was a big deal for me
though, man. T two for Mike,
for me and my guys to work with you guys
because you've said this on the podcast
and I know,
I know how organizations can,
we're not necessarily parochial
that we don't trust other people,
but we get really comfortable how we do
business and to just bring in another
group of dudes. I think this also speaks
volumes to desk and all those guys.
You're going to just, you want to make
sure those guys can keep up, you know,
and everybody knows that you guys are
legit man. And to keep up, you get,
you'd have to keep up,
you're gonna have to carry your own
weight and you're gonna have to make it
happen.
You're gonna have to provide something.
Cause at the minute you become
a drain on the, on the team.
You know you're going
to get cut loose and we,
we couldn't afford to be a drain on you
and we couldn't afford to have other
people be a drain on us.
So I think there's a lot of
kind of at the beginning of,
there isn't a lot of reasons
why it wouldn't have worked.
There's a whole bunch of reasons why it
wouldn't have worked and the only reason
it didn't work is it everybody was
committed to building a relationship to
support the battalion. That was it. We
all have the same end state in mind.
It wasn't about what can the seals do
to be seals and be great at it was what
can we do to support those guys? What's
the whole thing I was opening up with?
That's sort of where that came from.
It's just this attitude that
everybody there was on the same team,
straight up on the same team.
And so then that turned into big missions,
big missions pushing into Ramadi,
putting in the combat outpost, you know,
night after night, day
after day, doing those,
those big operations and
that relationship just got,
just got stronger and stronger. You
know, late Lafe obviously with you and,
and just turned into something really,
not just not just cool but man
affective. Yeah, effective.
It was, I mean, in that
deployment I kept a long journal.
Like I took a lot of notes
on my experience there and
I've gone back and we read
it a few times and I'm somewhat
recently throughout that whole thing.
One of the common themes is how
there'll be Lafe and I did this today,
our t we did stuff with you all the time
and it kind of became in that middle,
that kind of June, July, August.
I mean that was all we were really doing
because we were so busy and they're,
the big op was kicking off and we were
starting to get into downtown, but,
you know, I guess we'd never been
all these clearings, all that stuff.
And so the need for us to support the
army in the need for you to support the
army again,
we could've had 10 times as many of folks
and we probably still could have done
more work. Um, everything in that journal
is just about what we're doing together.
I think at the time I just kind of lost
track of it cause we were just everyday
get up and go do something.
I mean there was no down days,
there was hardly ever any time
when we weren't doing anything.
And it was almost always with
you guys. Um, and it was a
huge highlight for me, uh,
to,
to be with a group of guys that were so
on board with just making things happen.
You guys had an incredible knack of this
is in the way or this process keeps it,
yeah,
we got that sorted out.
Hey I need to get Airpoints oh well you
have to do this and this. No, no, no.
We get,
we get this sorted out.
So you guys had kind of had cornered the
market on what do you need? We'll make,
we'll get it, we'll make
it happen. And for me, um,
to be able to get that asset
sort of delivered that I could,
and you did all the work to get it,
but I can control the hell out of it.
Right on man. I didn't have to do any of
the work to explain why I needed this.
Cause you guys did all that work
and you had a valid reason for it.
They would have laughed at me if I said
I wanted an ac one 30 gunship like who
are you?
I'm Dave Burke man and I'm like negative
Leif and Jocko need and they see what
30 gun ship. Not every time, you
know, obviously it was a thin acid,
but when nothing showed up
overhead and then you get,
the guy we're talking about is like, you
want to control this? I'm like, yes I do.
I want to control this thing.
So there's a lot of mutual benefit there.
And I think what we also proved as I
think for the battalion of the brigade,
they figured out that we were really
helpful in helping those guys accomplish
what they wanted to accomplish.
And that was just,
I'm not putting very good
words to it right now, but
as obviously rule rewarding.
And it was the highlight of that
deployment is our ability to work together
through,
like I said,
there's a whole laundry list of reasons
why we shouldn't be able to do this a
bunch. You didn't work for me.
I did not rank you your guy.
There's just a whole bunch
of institutional roadblocks
that we could just stay
in our own corners and our own thing and
you and I could have never met and that
wouldn't have really been
all that uncommon. It would
have just been ops normal.
Um, and work out man. Yeah,
a lot of awesome highlights
on that deployment.
And obviously some of the worst
days of our lives are over there.
June 20th.
Talk to me about that. Yeah, man. Um,
so obviously I know we're
going to talk about this. Um,
so we had been there quite a bit and I
remember kind of the shock when we first
got there talking to the two to eight.
First Day I'm there,
I go to Alpha Company and they've got
a memorial outside of their compound of
all the soldiers that have been killed.
I can picture it.
It's just kind of like a names
are on a little placard in,
it's kind of a tall little pyramid looking
thing with the names on there and you
see it, you understand it. Hey,
people have died here. You get it.
It's not hard to, to understand
that those things have happened,
but there's this a level of disconnect.
When you first get there, you're like, oh,
people are dying, but you don't, you
haven't seen it. And then, you know,
very quickly,
I think probably my second mission out
there was a kind of a QRF from a vehicle
id. So basically, uh, um,
in a surgeon with a bunch of bombs in his
vehicles got on between American Combo
and blew himself up. So I see
my first dead body, you know,
I see this real combat people are dying
here. It was an enemy wasn't the same.
And then, you know, March, April, May,
we started taking, I
mean, not start a week,
continue to take casualties and I'm
starting to go to memorials and we're
starting to see guys that we knew and
worked with and were friends with and
built relationships with.
And they're, they're,
they're getting killed or
really greatly wounded.
And those memorials started to become
every couple of days we're going to a
memorial.
And that sort of weighs on you.
I've thought about this a lot
and how it affected me, you know,
was a pilot being out of my comfort
zone in this environment and,
and what that was like.
Okay.
But without trying to
diminish any of that loss,
there's a, there's a disconnect when it's
not your person when it's not your guy.
And on June 20th so Chris Leon,
who was my radio operator,
we are in a building that we had been
in, let me back up. I was not there.
I had left that building that morning.
Gone back to the COC.
Adam's team with Chris had replaced us
and we're basically just going back and
forth operations in this,
this combat outposts cause it gave us
a really good view of the north part of
the city. And we had to be
there basically 24, seven and,
and Chris and Adam team had gone back
out there and they were supposed to go
from like 12 to four,
something like that on what it was.
We gave them like a six
hour shift or something.
And then we're going to kind of figure
out if we replace her start over,
we had just sort of send them out there
and we're going to come back in a little
bit and I got a call on the radio
from the battalion saying, Hey,
can you extend your Anglico
team out here for four hours?
We're going to go do another movement
to do some clearing again, Roger that,
Hey Adam, can you guys stay up for an a
couple another couple of hours, you know,
support, we're going to get Jay or
whatnot, you know, standard answer. Yeah.
Roger that no problem.
And in during that time
it was not uncommon to take
fire. And from that, in that oop.
And there were some sniper fire.
And the first shot, uh,
there was a younger marine,
lance corporal who was up there and Chris
ran up from the other side and kind of
put, put him down, you know, say, hey,
why don't you get down and take cover, go,
go over to the other side of the building.
And Chris got up to start to, he was a,
he was doing his observation to
try to figure out what's going on.
And Chris was shot by a sniper
and I get a call can have very,
very closely after that
from Adam. You know, I'm,
I'm kind of manning the radios all the
time anyway. And even in our home base,
they're like, where we had a radio right
there. So I was never really not there.
I was just on the radio and said, hey,
core have been hit. We're on our way back.
And that was about it.
So I didn't have any real good
sense of anything that was going on.
And I'm a little panic
sets in like, okay. Um,
and I don't want to press
for too much information.
I get a call from Alpha company who had
w who manned all the observation posts
between where he was and where
we were that they were clearing,
make sure the roads were clear,
they're using their tanks and Bradleys
so they could pick them up and bring a
straight shot.
Cause that was a pretty dangerous road.
You guys had to look out
for ids and stuff like that.
And so everybody's kind of picking
up the pace to clear out that road.
And he's coming back and I get
a call, hey, he's breathing. Uh,
we're heading straight to Charlie
med. And I'm like, all right. Okay.
I kind of had this sense of
this is going to be okay. Um,
Charlie Med is this
medical facility on the,
the camp that we were stationed at there
and there's literally a hundred yards
from where I slept and I just ran down
to Charlie med, uh, to meet the Humvee.
I was there and I, I'm
sorry, it wasn't a hobby.
It was a Bradley Bradley Fighting
Vehicle broadly pulls up myself and my,
my corpsman doc are there, the, the,
the Bradley has a door on the back of
the amount of that comes down like a ramp
and the ramp comes down.
He's on a stretcher. Dot.
Goes up to get the front
piece of the stretcher.
I'm at the bottom and he comes down
carrying the stretcher and Chris is laying
on the stretcher and I, he went
right by me. I looked at him,
I knew immediately that he was
gone. Just, I mean it was gone.
It was, I could see the entrance wound
at the whole thing was all kind of there.
They had stabilized and they've done
their best to kind of manage the what,
but there was no question that the
outcome had already played itself out and
Chris was gone. They take them
in to the medical facility. Um,
which I'd been in and you've been in a
dozen times for a whole host of different
reasons, but it always
been somebody else. I mean,
I may have known that person
and been close to that person,
but it was always somebody else.
And doc goes in with him,
he's carrying the stretcher and he comes
out and probably Juncos play 10 seconds
and he just comes out with a head shaking.
And I knew I wasn't holding my breath,
I knew,
but he kinda came out and,
and just sort of I guess confirmed
if that's the word I'm looking for.
Just sort of made it official that,
that Chris had been killed.
And um,
it sort of initiated just a very
strange kind of very sequence of events.
So I,
I knew Adam and the rest of team we're
trying to get back and they're going to
have a slower road back cause they're
not going to get the support and it just
going to take a little more time to get
to get their gear and all the things go
along with that. Chris just got loaded
in a Humvee and racing back in a Bradley.
They're kind of load up their Humvees
and as it's going to take some time.
And I know like I need to
get back to the vehicle,
we park our trucks cause I want to
meet them there. And I walked back,
like I said, was maybe a hundred
yards from my hooch to Charlie Mann.
And I get about halfway there
and had this thought that,
that I maybe didn't confirm
that Chris was killed.
And so I actually walked
all the way back to go find,
there's a senior medical officer,
we call it on the snow.
Really awesome guy that dealt
with all the casualties there,
who I knew because I had done control.
I'd controlled helicopter,
castle vacs and wounded folks. I've
been there a lot. We did, we gave blood.
I mean we were in that
facility all the time.
And I, if I don't know why I
needed to do it, but I was,
I on my, I just, I had to
talk to him that hey is,
is corporately on as busy as he
killed. And he was like, yeah,
I'm sorry man. You know, it was
kind of an odd conversation.
I could tell the why he
was looking at me like,
why are you asking me this question?
Like it just was one of those
things that I was in sort of,
I think it just a stage of disbelief
that as I walked back and I was going to
deliver the news,
I had sort of told myself like,
I can't tell them in case what if I'm
wrong because I never really went through
that. I saw him, I saw doc, but
there are no words were exchanged.
And I have,
that's a very odd like walking back
and forth a couple of times and kind of
sorting it out. And then, you know, my job
was, next thing I had to do is that Adam,
I watched the trucks pull up,
they all get out, you know,
four guys and everybody else had heard,
you know,
all the angle go teams that were there.
And we shared a facility with EOD
and working Belize. Everybody,
you know the word, what's past
was something had happened and I,
you know, hey, on core dead, um,
you know,
w we do something called,
I think it's called a hero flight and a
hero flights going to be at like 1600.
I got the information in like 10 minutes.
The,
the process of them
bringing in a casualty,
that casualty not surviving and then
move in. They had the thing wired. Um,
and I'd seen it done a bunch of times,
but it just, it was Chris, it was my guy.
He was a guy that I just knew differently
than everybody else and I just saw him
differently when we entered our trucks.
He was the back left and I was the front
right. And our trucks are always parked,
backed into their spots so
they're always side by side.
So the back left of his truck enter door
and the right front of my truck door,
we always had to fight space
for each other. You know,
Chris was standard perfect marina.
Like he could be 90% of the way through.
If he saw me walking up, you'd get out
of the way, close the door to let me.
And I'm like, oh, come on dude.
Like just here's a great marine.
Just I walked past that kid without
even really talking to him, you know,
a thousand times, just every single
day, a couple of times a day. And,
um,
it,
it demystifies as a,
as a marine,
you just live a slightly bit for me.
I shouldn't say you how it felt for me
as I just felt with all that was going on
and all the destruction and the death
and the violence and all the things that
I'd sort of become
accustomed to at that point.
There's just an aspect of it that's just
a tiny bit insulated in your life to a
really small degree, but it's enough
to just keep you sort of preserved.
And
when Chris was killed,
it just sort of expose that.
It broke down one of my last
little boundary of I'm okay here,
cause I can do this because
I'm going to get through this,
I'm going to go home and
everything's gonna be okay. Um,
and that hurt a lot.
That hurt in ways that I did not
understand how it was going to hurt.
I just didn't, I just didn't know
what that was going to be like.
And the, the, the, all of those next steps
and you, I know you know this cause you,
you saw it,
he's on a helicopter and he's gone flying
away and that 46 and what feels like
about a minute, it's hours, an hour
even rehearse the movement onto the,
to carry him onto the hell.
But you go from Chris's city is on his
way into watching the helicopter fly away
and it feels like it's,
it takes about that long and then you're
just sort of left and you walk back.
You literally walk away from the medical
facility where the helicopter just
takes off and you walk back a hundred
yards and you just go back to your room.
Only Chris has gone and it's like
that whole deployment kind of re,
I don't know what the right word is,
is like I had to start the deployment
again because all the things that I was
dealing with and all things and
I was managing and leading as,
as the leader would know,
whatever you want it to say was my job.
It all just sort of change in
terms of what I thought really
the guys that I was working with,
everything was different now because
it was their brother that was gone,
not somebody else.
And it just sort of changed the calculus
and it really redefined the rest of
that deployment. And I'll
be really, really blunt.
It was hard for me to not fold and
there was a lot of instinct of like,
I did not want to do this anymore.
I do not want to be here.
This is more than I had bargained for.
And this,
we can laugh about volunteering
and being a marine, you know,
it was a little more than I
bargained for. And Look, man,
we had done some crazy stuff at that
point and I'd seen some bad things happen.
I was a participant in some
bad things and I had was okay,
I was doing okay and I was going to be
okay with that. And this one just sort of,
I just, I struggled with it a little
bit. So it was a tough day man.
Yeah, it obviously, you know,
for, for us it was, you know,
what, a month and a half later on
August 2nd when when mark got killed.
And you know,
I think that's one of the things that,
that we felt, you know, that little bit
of insulation that you're talking about.
We felt that we felt,
I will say,
I would say actually more
insulated because, you know,
my guys were out there
taking massive risks,
getting in crazy gunfights getting after
it to a degree that no one had ever
thought they would.
And we were doing all right.
We had a couple guys get wounded here
and there, but they were okay. And,
and honestly, that guy's
getting wounded, you know,
if it's not a devastating
moment, I mean, it had, you know,
one of my guys got wounded early on and
he almost lost his leg. But guess what?
He didn't, and that, that didn't make
us feel more vulnerable in my mind.
It made us feel stronger and like,
hey, we might get wounded, but what?
We're going to be good. And so
yeah, when mark got killed and,
and especially mark was,
you know,
such a gregarious and such a guy's so
full of life that you don't think he can
be killed.
You don't think it can be killed.
And same thing, you know, that
insulation was just completely shattered.
And I think what was also,
it was, it was recognizable,
it was recognizable to me,
was that
other people outside of task me to
bruiser, they thought the same thing.
They thought, hey, the seals are
here, they're gonna, they're gonna,
they're gonna push through this.
They're gonna,
they're gonna win and there nothing's
going to happen to them. And we saw it,
you know, at the memorial service you
could see in guys faces that they were,
they were also do their
installation about us was,
was kind of shattered tune
and then it turns into, damn,
if the seals can get killed,
where am I at?
And I think that was another
thing that, that really, you know,
that was another thing that really
just made market and killed such a,
such an impact to all of us
there, there, there's no doubt of that.
What you just said is
exactly how it played out.
You were the first guy to talk to me when,
when Chris has helicopter flies away,
it's literally like dusty and you know
the helicopters loud and it kicks up dust
there and it was dark. It was
nighttime. And you came up to me,
and I don't remember the exact words,
but we were just turning around and
walking back and you said something like,
we're going to get after this guys and
we're going to go find the snipers that
are doing something to those awards.
And it was basically like,
we're gonna take care of this. And I
remember feeling really comforted by that.
Like, yeah man, yeah, go
do that. That's awesome.
And feeling good about that,
that we weren't helpless and we're just
gonna suck it up and deal with this.
Just this terrible loss that we're
going to get something from this.
We're going to go find some guys and go
get after it and we're going to go kill
these guys. Yes, you got
and you guys were going to,
you guys are gonna make that happen.
And I remember feeling,
I remember how that felt and look,
June 20th to August 2nd,
just like everything else was a blur
man. It was like, it was like the,
it might as well just been the next day
because things happened so fast there.
And I was, you know, I wasn't on the
patrol, uh, on the, on August 2nd,
but I was on the radio.
There's a guy running the air.
I was doing all the same stuff.
We always did that, you know,
and I was back in the coc
with you working that mission,
all that stuff that happened.
And before you know it,
we're watching the helicopter
fly away. Um, you know, or
he's gone, you know, and you're,
and you're seeing the, the, the,
the aftermath of that.
And I actually went back last night to
look at my journal entry for that day
because I ended up running down to
Charlie met again because that's where
everybody came in. And I remember
seeing life there. You know,
life was a guy who worked with a ton
and there he is, he's got a wound.
I'm looking at it, I'm over it. I'm
standing over his right shoulder,
that kind of shirt there.
They're there,
they're attending delay who was life
was a larger than life, you know,
for a guy like me who always
kind of felt a little bit like,
what the hell am I doing here, man? What
the hell am I doing with the seals? Like,
this isn't sane.
These guys are just,
they're just larger than life.
And to see the exposure of of that it it,
it bothered me and I knew I
had the feeling of, holy cow,
if this can happen to these guys,
you know it can happen to any of
us and it's not a good feeling.
And when you saw the guys from the team
who were, it was just, it was just free.
It was scrambling and it
was just that sense of,
and I don't want to make it
sound like there wasn't a pinup.
He's panicking or freaking out.
It was not like that,
but it was just a tiny bit chaotic,
if that makes sense on a small degree.
But enough when you were so used to
just being completely not like that,
that feeling like when Chris loss
was what I felt was like, Oh man,
I'm not really in control any of this.
I am not in control.
All that stuff that I've told myself,
all that comfort and confidence and
we're getting better and I'm going to be
more effective and do more good
work until this thing is over.
It was like no negative. That could
be you. That could happen today.
And then,
and between Chris and mark,
the army suffered a horned,
God bless.
We don't go to memorials like every
couple of days people were getting killed
all the time at every
one of those eroded that,
that confidence a little bit. And then
when it happened to mark and Lafe,
that was hard to see that. Um, and it,
that was the feeling that I
had. I was like, um, yeah,
yeah,
maybe I'm just lucky, you know, maybe,
and maybe this whole thing is just luck.
Um,
now look,
we, we regrouped. I mean, June 20th,
it was a bad day. You know,
we did all the things we do,
the more oil we paid our are, we honored
him the right way. You guys came out.
We did it the right way and we
acknowledged, uh, Chris, um,
but if you kind of think of what's going
on in Ramadi in the middle of June, man,
there was no taking a knee. There was
no like, let's hold off for a second,
catch our breath, the bullet train, which
is running. And as a matter of fact,
it was just going to, it was actually
just going to get a ton worse.
So you remember July and August were
just, they were insane. They were insane.
So we, we lost Chris really at
the big ramp up. Right. You know,
we had done a big movement in earlier in
June and we were really starting to lay
into the city. But the real, you
know, the crazy j block, you know,
that kind of stuff, that stuff
was all out in front of us. Um,
and so for me it was,
you know,
my entire career I've done a whole bunch
of really great stuff on my career.
Nothing has even,
nothing is even is any more talking
about what anything else in my career has
meant compared to that deployment.
And then that day, I mean,
it's just light years
different. Um, and it was like,
hmm,
you got to get up and go do it the
very next day. And it's a four.
I remember going that first patrol,
that first mission and trying to
is that feeling of, okay, yeah,
it's different. And you got,
I think you've got one or
two ways to go with that.
It's either going to get inside your
head and kind of mess with you and break
you a little bit, and I could feel
that happening or you just, you just,
you just don't, you just shut
it down and just go do it. Um,
and I found how to compartmentalize.
You know, I'd come back,
I'd have moments when I was back on
my hooch up on the roof by myself.
I have my moments, man. No, I don't
want anybody to think that I didn't. Uh,
I had plenty of those moments. As
a matter of fact, I, I still do.
To be honest with you,
I still have my moments.
I go visit Chris and
Arlington on his birthday.
I go visit Chris in the day he was killed.
I go to go visit Chris Memorial Day.
His mom comes out, I see cat.
She and I are very close.
Um, I have my moments without a doubt. Um,
but the rest of the three months
in Ramadi that it was just not,
there wasn't a ton of time to do that. So
I guess I kinda just saved it maybe, uh,
for, for when I came back and it
was their minute. It's not good.
But um, yeah man. So
then you do come back and I
mean obviously like you said,
it ramped up, it ramped up all
the time and the guys were just,
you know, everybody, Larry, I'm
not just talking about our guys.
I'm talking about everybody. It ramped
up hardcore. It got hotter outside the,
the, the combat got more intense,
the enemy started fighting harder.
They got more squared away.
And
like you said,
you and the rest of the guys there
did the mission day after day,
night after night,
and then one day you fly home.
Yup.
And how was that transition
for you getting back to yeah,
the states. Uh, interesting.
It was an interesting transition.
So
from the time that I left Ramadi, so you
would pack up our stuff. We left for,
I think we went to Kuwait for a day or
two. Went to Le Jeune, went to Japan,
cause I had a checkout at both places.
Jack,
I think it was six days on the calendar
from the day I left for the today I did
the day I landed on a plane in San Diego.
Um,
which at the time was all I wanted.
I was the,
and I've been fairly good about this
throughout my career is when I want things
to happen administrative, we, I can
make those things happen by him getting,
if I catch one that there's a flight
from Japan to San Diego and I can get on
that flight,
I'm going to get on that flight.
And even with my CEO is yell at me like,
how did you get out of here so fast?
And like I have this thing in the guy and
the paper I got to go and I'm out. Um,
I wanted to get out quickly.
Uh,
so I found myself in San Diego
executing my next orders,
which the Marine Corps had said,
you go to [inaudible],
you do the it factor
and go to do the factor,
you're going to go back to San Diego
from there, which will be your,
your next set of orders.
So I knew while I was in Iraq
that San Diego was in my future.
My wife had already moved down there.
I told you she was living
with my best friend Neil,
who was on that factor before me. So I
go in Ramadi, his battalion comes home,
we show up. My wife and my best friend
are living together in San Diego. Uh,
which was really good for her because
he was able to kind of keep her aware of
what's going on,
but knew exactly how to explain it in a
way that wasn't going to freak her out.
And he also, to be honest with, you
know, how to downplay, I would call, hey,
we're doing this. No big
deal. I mean, I didn't,
I wasn't telling them half of what
the hell was going on. I, we can't,
you're not going to share those stories.
So he was a really great resource for her.
I paid very little time worrying about it,
to be honest with you.
I was comfortable that, that she
had a good support structure, um,
which she really didn't.
We, we got married, uh,
I deployed for months later to Ramadi.
She,
she started dating a dude who was driving
a corvette and living in Tokyo as a
top gun instructor and informants
after we got married, I was in Ramadi,
so there was no like easing.
So I knew there was just, I didn't
know at the time I didn't think of it,
but it was obvious that looking back
that she was just thrown into an
environment that she was
totally unprepared for that
forget about just me being
gone. But just the fact that I was
in Ramadi, it's all over the news.
Everybody who was going on,
I think one of my marines is killed
in a lot of crazy stuff going on.
And next thing you know,
I'm home September 20th I'm back in
San Diego like 365 days to the day.
I'm home and I checked
into an Fatz squash.
And like the day after I got home before
October 1st I was back anyone Fatz
squash and San Diego, which is insane. Um,
and I, to be really
blunt, I was, you know,
all those guys in Angola went back to
Anglico and Campbell are zoon in camp, uh,
Hanson and, and Japan. I was like, wait,
later Bros, you know, like no longer buys,
you know, high five great
deployment. Uh, you know, I'm out.
I was just on to other things and I kind
of extricated myself. It's, you know,
I followed the rules to do whatever's
supposed to do and before I know it,
I'm back there.
And I honestly,
I think also kind of kicking myself like
that was the be the best thing for me.
Let's,
let's get home.
I knew something was amiss because
on the drive home from the airport,
I fly to San Diego international
just down the road. My wife and my,
my mom who lives in San Diego,
both of them saying it came to
pick him up from the airport.
You've already met my mom.
Great Lady.
My wife and my mom picked
me up from the airport.
I got pictures of them meeting
me there and get in the car,
drive from San Diego International to
our house in Pacific beach and as repoing
like onto Chels Sydney up to the house.
Um, I like screamed at him and told him
to stop talking or something like that.
I said something like, I don't even
know. I don't know what it was,
but I think I just remember sitting in
the passenger seat and some the gears are
just start, I'm in a truck or a car,
whatever. I don't know what it was,
but something's going on in. And I think
just the pressure is building and um,
and I have no sense of what's going on.
No alet for it.
And they're like having a perfectly normal
adult conversation that might've been
an octave above what I was willing
to accept or tolerate maybe.
And I completely freaked out on my
wife and my mom went and seen in a year
and you know, they were like,
oh, sorry, you know, they
were super cool, no pushback.
And I was, it was an indicator
like, yeah, you're right.
You recognize that immediately.
You're like, Oh God, Yep. Immediately.
And it was that combination
recognition of that's not good.
And clearly I have,
I have things I need to deal with that
I wasn't quite aware of. So a new,
no question right away.
And I think, you know,
think about this a lot
with other marines and,
and the things he experienced in combat.
And you've talked about PTSD a lot. Look
as a subject you'd spend hours on.
The bottom line is everybody
deals with things differently.
It doesn't mean you're
broken or messed [inaudible].
It just means you have some processes
you got to go through and you gotta deal
with.
And we all deal with it differently.
I had maybe talked myself into how
it's 33 as a fairly experienced guy.
I was surrounded by very young marines
who maybe in my mind didn't have maybe
the emotional, uh, maturity,
maybe the life skills to maybe manage
some of these same chaotic things.
You know, guys that saw
Chris gets shot, you know,
I may be kind of built
myself up a little bit.
I was a little better equipped and I was
better equipped in my mind and I was,
I in a matter of 45 minutes
from the airport to the house,
I'm flying off the handle
on something. So, um,
it just all it was, man, it was,
it was those two things like that's not
good and this is gonna probably happen
again. I'm going to need to, I'm
going to do to think about this.
I can't pretend like I'm not going
to just have some sort of residual,
you can't leave Ramadi,
be in San Diego six days later and
not bring some baggage home with you.
And I was bringing some baggage home.
Um,
and there were some baggage
there a little bit. Uh,
so that transition was, was it started?
Is there anything that like the,
anything that helped you? Yeah, Dude.
I'll tell you what helped the most is my
best friend who had been in Ramadi and
endured all of that loss.
Look our story. You know, the,
the guys that we replaced,
the guys that replaced us,
it's a very similar story a lot.
They understand that, you know,
I think having an outlet,
having one other dude,
and it happened to be my best
friend, super 14. So it was,
you want to talk about just hitting the
Jackpot on being the best equipped to
sort of just deal in power through
it and accept what's going on and,
and embrace it and all of those
things that go along with it.
I had an outlet man.
I had my best friend who knew,
I mean he knew every place we were. I
mean it wasn't even like, oh he was here.
It was the same place. Cause Ramande not
that big. It's just not that big man.
And so he say, I was on the corner of
sunset and Michigan. He's like, yeah,
been there a hundred times. Yeah. Um, and,
and he was struggling a bit to, you
know, again, it's all relative. I mean,
were handled relatively okay.
You know,
I'm going back to kind of
dealing in a normal life and,
but the moments when you get those little
spikes and those is what kind of comes
up and get you those little spikes.
Those are unperceived kind of reactions.
He could see that in me and I could see
that in him and we actually been real.
We're really good for each other.
When I see him kind of get a little shaky,
a little break, like I'm not, you know,
he's not digging his environment a
little bit or he'd see that in me.
You had that other person that kind
of bring you back to helping you,
helping you to deal with that, which
is good. The flip side of that,
while it was really helpful
for him to be there,
I think it was really tough on Whitney
because she was not my outlet for that.
I wasn't kind of got cut out
totally and not at, I didn't,
certainly not by design. I'm not like
doing this calculation of I don't want my,
she just not, I'm not going to use
her as a resource, you know, for that.
And to be honest with you too,
there's also a little part of me know
what the corner of Michigan and sunset is
like. So totally man. And I'll,
I'll be really candid, you know,
I think I would have been almost
embarrassed is maybe not the right word,
but I wasn't, I don't know if I
wanted her to see that pirate party,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and they check out this ridiculous amount
of vulnerability that I have right now
that I'm going to carry with me for God
knows how long that's going to come up
out of nowhere and you're going to have
to just deal with it. So there was a,
I think the thing that bothered me the
most and was part of just kind of getting
back to day to day life was it,
I would get when things didn't go well,
when I had my moments, my reaction
was just I just get pissed off.
It was that feeling of I have
this like some event, what happen?
Something stupid would catch my attention
and kind of heighten my, you know,
my response.
And because it happened,
I'd be in order to myself that I let it
let it bother me and that'd be pissed
off at myself because I let it bother me.
You know what I mean?
Like this ridiculous cycle of, I
told you the story the other day, um,
my wife and I shoot,
I guarantee she remembers
the store or walking across
the street downtown. No, no.
By the beach I think.
And A,
an auto body shop is running the air
drill to pull some tires off of can route,
you know that, that kind of
sound. And as we're walking,
I think my left arm is over her,
her shoulder were walking like this.
I hear that sound and my first reaction
is I pushed her down to the ground.
And in the time that it takes
to do that and catch that,
it's happening is maybe a
third of a second. You know
what I mean? So I hear it,
I do the eye, I'm reacting
and pushing her to the ground.
I'm kind of getting on top of her to
do, look what a two, oh, that's the car.
It's not a thing.
There's no reason for you to do
this is about a third of a second.
And what bothered me the most
about it is that I did it.
Not that I felt like that is that I
reacted to it and I was like embarrassed,
like what's wrong with me to go through
that? And she's like, what the, you know,
and um, I, it sounded like, you know,
kind of going through the whole
thing and I think just the, the,
the fact that I had responses pissed me
off and I would just kind of, honestly,
I have a temper about it and that was,
she got to see me just get pissed
off at stuff for no real good reason,
which you never really get
pissed off. Like, I mean,
I have tempers, a pet,
just stuff that just did,
I would get mad about stuff that
just didn't make sense. I mean,
I have a temper about things that when I
get my computer pisses me off just like
it pisses you off man. And that's
totally normal. Right. I would get,
I would have reactions to stuff that
just, there was no way for her to say, oh,
that makes sense. I understand. It
would just be this totally odd ball.
Somebody would say something wrong.
Just,
it would just trigger in ways that she
would look at me and kind of be like,
who are you? She knew all my flaws. She
knows everything right in along with me.
And all of a sudden now I'm
doing all this other stuff.
Put another little thing in
the, yes, add that to the mix.
So I got my wife who we get
married, I leave, I go on
this deployment, I come back,
I'm home for maybe seven months before
I deployed again in that seven months,
you know, welcome to marriage
to Dave Burke. You know,
that involves a year long deployment,
seven months in Iraq, you know,
God only knows what the Hell I
was. You know, I'm back to work.
So I'm back at a squadron as the Xo,
you know,
working ridiculous XO hours in a
fighter squadron prepping up to go on a
deployment.
I voluntarily extend my
time to make the deployment,
which is exactly what you should do
at the beginning of your marriage is
volunteer to extend on a deployment.
I got accepted into Grad school,
I was going to go to Dartmouth,
I was getting out of the Marine
Corps is going to go to get my Mba.
And I remember the conversation of Hey,
I'm going to extend.
It asked me to extend and you know,
explaining why I was going to do what I
was going to do. And she was like, why?
Why would you do that? And
I said, so I can deploy.
And you hear those words like God,
I just say that to my wife. Like,
which is so I cannot be with you so I
can be apart from you so I can hang out
with the boys and go do that. You know
what I mean? Not Retired from the marines.
Get Out of the Marine Corps so I can
not do all these other things that I not
set up this future that I told you
all about and sold you on it. Totally.
So to say that my wife and,
and everybody's got those stories,
the laundry list of reasons why she
should have just sort of cut bait and be
like,
no,
this is not happening is a lot longer
than the list of reasons why she shouldn't
have.
And props were good where she is
here and my marriage with her,
uh, you know, for all the ups and downs,
it goes long as everybody's marriage.
The one thing I don't worry about,
even even when we're at our worst,
at our absolute worst, which
are worst, is whatever it is,
we have our worst moments
at our absolute worst.
I don't have a shred and we
have a brain cell of thought of,
I wonder if our marriages are going to
survive this. You know, this throw down,
we're having over,
God knows what you know.
So we kind of went through
the fire there and she,
she got forged. Yeah, big
time. She's a stud. Uh,
she deserves mad props for going through
that because I'm not really sure why
she did, to be honest with
you. She said, no, I can't.
I can't come up with
any good reasons either.
She had a lot of options on the table.
I'm not sure. Uh, yeah, so it was,
that transition was tough man.
So now you're in another squadron.
You go on deployment again,
which is another one.
What are you doing on that deployment?
Just more so.
I'm back in FAA squash and
I'm the Xo and the opposite.
I actually did both jobs on this
deployment and we just go to Japan.
It's a Westpac,
so western Pacific.
We're back in CUNY and a and
Okinawa just doing exercises,
exercises or training, that kind
of stuff. Get done with that.
And so now maybe it's time to
get out of the Marine Corps.
Before I left and that deployment,
I had told my commander,
the the group commander and the squadron
commander, Hey, this isn't for me.
I'm hanging it up.
It's been awesome.
I happily to extend for this deployment
that they needed me to go on.
It was great experience. I got to train
a bunch of young guys. Life was good,
but they knew before I left that I was
going to be out of the Marine Corps.
At the end of that I differed
at Dartmouth for a year,
paid my nonrefundable deposit,
which I have never gotten back.
It wasn't why they call it not fundable.
Absolutely.
My point is I wasn't kicking
around the idea of getting out.
I was in full execution. We had looked
at houses like we are in execution.
This was merely a detour to get to that
end state and what I'm due back from
that deployment in January,
I think it is of the following year and
it turns out that the
Marine Corps wants to uh,
extend a guy to go fly f 20 twos for the,
with the air force for three years and
they're accepting applications for the f
22 raptor exchange, which had never been
happened before. Never happened since.
It was a onetime thing and the
guy got it, they picked, you know,
it was going to go to non deploying
in Nellis and fly the have 22 raptor.
I should probably apply.
I guess it just seems like a reasonable
thing to do because then if they say no,
then we'll just go get my
MBA. It's all good. Um,
and Lo and behold, uh,
at the end of December,
I get the word that I got picked
up for this raptor exchange. Um,
and I, you know, I remember calling
Whitney, I'm like, hey babe,
totally. She knows what's up. And I
did the standard Dave Burke oversell.
Hey, no deploying. We're
going to go to, you know, it's
all, here's all the goodness.
There's no downside, you know, and
she's like, shut up. You know, she's a,
and she was good with it and
you know, it was a, it was,
it was just another one of those
things. Like, I can't say no to this.
This is just something that doesn't
happen and you just don't get to,
nobody gets a fly.
They have 22 in the Marine Corps because
the merger was a plan of 20 twos,
same thing I said when I've left sixteens
and top gun and all this sort of stuff.
So it was just another thing that I just
couldn't believe was happening and I
couldn't leave the Marine Corps saying I
walked away from that. I just couldn't.
And she was totally on board and came
home and didn't get back my nonrefundable
deposit and a move to Vegas and started
flying the have 22 raptor three years up
there. And then at some
point that role was oh yeah.
And that rolls into the f three,
five at some point. So I, I'm fine.
[inaudible] um, how many people
were flying the f 22 at this point?
So we probably had,
I knew at the time what number I was,
I think I might've been in the
hundreds something, you know,
we had two squadrons that
were stood up and you know,
and it was starting to pick up,
the pace was early 2008 so the raptor
was just starting to get its legs
underneath it. We started building more
and it was starting to become a thing.
And the Marine Corps had this
idea that they're going to,
they're going to build this new stealth
airplane called the f 35 and they are
going to get it.
And they wanted someone to go to the
air force to learn all the airplanes are
really similar.
There's a goal,
steal all their experience and all the
pain that they've gone through to stand
up this thing and then you're going
to bring it back to the Marine Corps.
So the deal was this f 22 Gig was,
it was really high probability.
I was gonna go right from the of 22
to the of 35 and command the first
operational squadron. And Lo and behold,
man, that's exactly what happened.
We went to Tyndall,
we lived in Tyndall for three months
when I went through training and that was
awesome.
We're living on the beach in,
in Florida for three months to get
trained in the raptor when we move out to
Vegas. Um, lived there for three
plus years, started a family too.
My first two kids were born in Las Vegas.
We're, we're killing it, man. I mean,
it was awesome.
And as I'm getting ready to leave Vegas,
I get selected to command the first
operational. There was a guy there before,
they didn't have airplanes, they had a
guy, there was another CEO before me,
but I was going to go out there and
accept and start flying the first f 35 of
the Marine Corps. I show up and this poor
guy was selected to do the same thing,
you know, two years prior.
Great Dude. But he, you know,
we'd stayed in touch and I were always
in contact and helping them stand up with
everything. And, and I get
there, Jocko, I'm there,
I think two days and the first airplane
showed up and I'm like, what's the,
what's the big deal?
He spent two years in,
see a single airplane working
all this paperwork, grinding,
doing all this administrative stuff
to prep. He gets no airplanes.
You show up two days later,
boom.
Do the amount of work that him and
his guys went through to stand up the
squadron. And I literally showed
up at to work in the next day.
The first airplane landed. Yeah. That's
my new nickname for you. You're like,
this really isn't that hard,
van, what's the big deal?
And he and I did a turnover and
he left and sort of flying up 35.
Um, and you know, that's a whole part of
my career. We could spend hours on that.
But I flew the raptor,
which was an amazing airplane and I flew
the up 35 which was amazing airplane
and I, and I got to totally
be relevant in aviation.
I had sort of exhausted. I did all
the things I wanted to do in a hornet.
I love that airplane. I did top can,
I kind of had reached all the things,
and we talked about this too,
when when you leave top gun,
you're never going to
be that good ever again.
So it was just a matter of how slow you
can make the process of getting worse.
It's just how can you slow it down to
be as good as you can knowing that you
will never be as good as you
were there because you're,
you're never going to get the reps again
ever. You're just never going to get it.
And so it's just a matter of kind
of slowing down that process.
And at some point in your mind,
like,
I don't want to be in this business
if I'm not at the top of my game.
When I flew the of 22 I didn't
have a job. I didn't, I wasn't,
I wasn't the opposite of a squadron,
which is what I just showed up and
I just show up and flew the plane.
I had some leadership responsibility
in, in the organization, showed up,
grab the keys from someone, take
it out, run it into the ground,
write a little report and be like,
bring your bag again.
The keys back to the maintenance guys
and yeah, hey, this thing's broken.
Give me another one. Um, it was
your deal day. It was awesome. Yeah.
So I did that totally
great for my marriage.
I was able to combine all these
professional interests with great,
which you don't get to do in the Marine
Corps when there's a war going on.
You just don't get to do that.
And here I am and do.
I had no more friends in the
Marine Corp Man. Nobody liked me.
They're all doing back to back to back
deployments and airplanes are breaking
and um, I'm living in Vegas, fly on
the rafter. All my bros were like,
we're done with you, man. We've got
nothing for you. So, you know, I was just,
I almost felt guilty. I did not feel
guilty, but it almost did. Almost did a,
and then I go out to, and we moved
to Destin, Florida, you know, or,
or Fort Walton beach and we'll live in
Knightsville and this awesome house in
this great community.
And I was the first pilot to ever fly
the F 35 be operationally in the world.
Like ridiculous. I did that for like
two and a half years and it was awesome.
And then you, what
brought you up to DC? Um,
so what rob got to DC.
So I was,
I was so sure that I was going to leave
the Marine Corps after that command tour
or they have 35 that I reapplied to.
Dartmouth got back in again.
It got accepted to, do you have to give
him another deposit? Um, no, I was,
I was smart enough not to pay the
deposit because there's a tiny little
possibility that wasn't gonna
work out. Anyway, I did get
into Dartmouth again. It,
it's like, Babe, I'm going to go to get
my Mba. I've always wanted to get my MBA.
And um,
I got selected for an academic fellowship
where it basically got to go to Grad
School for a year.
I went to and said they sent me the Johns
Hopkins University to get my masters
and I basically went to DC and
it was a civilian for a year.
Between those two things is
another terrible deal. It's like,
can the Marine Corps,
I'd like to pay you to go be a fulltime
student at Johns Hopkins, which,
which they did.
Um,
so we moved up to DC and I went to Johns
Hopkins and got my masters and then the
next thing they offered
you is to go back and yeah.
So from there the payback of that
good deal was to go to the Pentagon,
which was totally reasonable thing.
I post command,
I had been to school and you know,
it's certainly couldn't complain about
how tough my life was in the Marine Corps
since, you know, the last eight
years or whatever. It was a,
and I just went basically did a desk
job in the Pentagon, uh, and uh,
worked for and the Joint Staff and the
chairman of Joint Chiefs of Staff and
just working some project. It wasn't all
that exciting. It was, I learned a bunch,
but it was just kind of a kind of a
mad job. I was, you know, very nine,
five strict hours. Don't take
work home. We know blackberry,
no real responsibility. Pretty
chill life. Life was pretty good.
Um, I selected, I picked up
colonel while I was there. Um,
the end of 2015,
I was selected for colonel and uh,
in the summer of 2016,
I selected for command again as a
colonel this time to command and have 35
squadron.
Um,
but
I didn't want to do that.
I don't know how this is going to come
across to the people listening and what a
terrible dealer was.
The marine corps acid,
would it be a curl and go flap 35
is again, and I'm not, I'm not,
I don't want this to come across
it. I was complaining, but what I,
the one thing that I, and all those great
deals in, dude, they were great deals.
The thing that I was missing the most
was that I always kind of felt like I had
a one foot in one foot out.
They were these non deploying jobs,
the air force exchange. Um, the,
the FPT five job was kind of standing up
a squadron and we weren't prepping for
anything and I loved it,
but I could feel sort of
underneath the surface,
like a lack of investment.
I could tell I just wasn't,
I didn't have to be a hundred set
pot committed because there was no,
we're going to go to deploy,
we're going to go to,
there was no thing that
was going to happen.
And I think one of the healthiest
things about being in the Marine Corps,
you're always prepping for something.
Yeah.
So even in the crappy stuff you
don't want to do, you know, hey,
we got to do this because the end state
is this and I was missing that and it
sort of over time started to erode a
little bit that I did is I was catching
myself. I know in the we'll slack in
the line, to be honest with you, I,
to be really blunt, I didn't have to
bring my a game every day. I just didn't,
I could do the things that I was doing
so in an airplane because there was just
an element that there was no
outcome to what I was preparing for.
And I started to kind
of find other interests.
Like school became
really interesting to me.
I did that year and so I
continued my education,
Johns Hopkins and started working towards
my Mba because I needed something or
wanted something else.
And once you kind of catch in your mind
that the Marine Corps and what they're
asking you to do.
I was going to go back to a training
squash and I wanted to go to be an
operational commander with
operational units that are praying,
preparing to go something.
I wasn't going to get to do that.
I was going to go back to a training
environment. I caught myself
losing the thing that was
the most passionate about
the marine corps and seeing
it's more of like, okay, three years here,
this will get me to this retirement
and this amount of money,
and it was just starting to become a
little too professional and not enough
about a passion. And I don't
mean to say I was going to need,
needed to feel like a 21 year old again.
I I,
you don't need to recreate it like that.
But my wife actually sat me down.
We were talking and she just kind
of looked at me and he's like, dude,
you're not going to be happy doing this.
It was really clear to her,
I think even more clear
than it was for me.
It's hard to come across as ungrateful,
but I
okay,
I could,
I was not going to be good at that job
because there was something that was
missing. It was something that I didn't,
there was nothing that I about it,
that it made me feel passionate about
doing it. So no joke, man. Last year,
August, I basically told
her I declined command,
I declined promotion and to put them
for retirement all the same day.
And that was a big move,
man. It's a big move.
That created a little splash out
there in the world. Maybe. Uh,
it was, it didn't, it surprised everybody.
But my wife obviously
she was totally got it.
I knew it was the right thing
and my closest buddies, I
mean I talked to my Bros,
my tight, my Bros, those
guys understood. But yeah,
it was a big move and I was turning
down what by whole by all rights was a
really good, great deal. Another
great deal. Doubt about it. But,
and then at some point you show up at a
different kind of event in Virginia with
Lafe and I working with a company
for our company Ashkelon Front,
we're doing a leadership
training for a company.
And you decided to come down
and check it out. Lay said,
come on down and check this out. See
what you think of this. Yeah. So life.
Talk to me a couple of years ago and when
I was leaving that f 35 dropped before
I went up to DC and he's like, Hey
man, Jack and I are doing this thing.
It's going to be awesome. Um, we'd love
to talk to you about it. And I'm like,
Hey man,
I'm all in on this other gig.
I'm going to school and go to the Marine
Corps. And we stayed in touch. I mean,
life was a buddy. I mean, he's
a guy that that I appreciate it.
You have the Times that we reconnected
here and there and I certainly
appreciated the call, but it just
really wasn't in the calculator.
I wasn't really, I wasn't there.
So when I told him like, hey man,
I dropped my letter, uh, I'm
getting out. Um, and like I said,
life isn't always the easiest guy to get
ahold of right away to talk sometimes.
He's, he's got a lot on his
plate as a busy guy. And he
texted, he texted me back,
right then I'm on the bus
leaving the Pentagon is a, Hey,
do you have time to talk right now? Yeah,
I knew. So he calls me and we talked for,
I mean, probably a solid 45 minutes
to an hour. And he's like, Hey,
jack and I are going to be up in
Vienna here in a couple of weeks.
Why don't you come out for
the day? I'm like, okay. Right
on. And He, and he gave me,
you know, I like, I was following
you guys and I knew it was going on.
I was seeing what you're doing
and things were blown up.
I was certainly bragging on my,
my buddy's Leif and Jocko to anybody
that will listen to me about it. Um,
and I watched you, you
know, you and laugh,
give this presentation up there
in Vienna to this group. And um,
dude
you were,
it was awesome man who were sitting with
a smile on your face when we, you know,
we got done and that first
day and we sat down with you,
you were in big town. You're
like I am in, I want to do this,
this is all you were. You were pumped.
And then I think that was, you know,
and then, and then actually
we did, I brought you up and
we did an event with another company
and that you're now involved with for a
long term and, and even then, you know,
cause then cause then for us, you know,
I wanted to see what you are going to
do and see how you are going to do it.
And Man, I was like, I don't know,
you gave your first two
paragraphs of talking, you know,
your first two minutes of, of explaining
something. I was like okay cool, I'm good.
And I was, you know, just everything that
we talk about all the time, you know,
that's in the book and
hearing you describe things
from the book but with your
view on it and your angle and
it's, it's, it's refreshing to me.
And also I'm just, I mean
I'm even learning, right?
So I'm hearing a different angle and
like I talk about with, with everything,
it was like we just talked about with,
with flying at top gun or like it
isn't Jujitsu where like it isn't the
battlefield,
the more different angles you can see
something from the better you're going to
get at it. And so here I am listening to
you going, Oh, there's another angle. Yup,
here we go. So that was awesome.
And it was also the first time,
you know, with Jp, same
thing, you know, I,
I I listened to Jay but it's like the
first time JP who came with me and he was
just sitting in the back like
what you did the first time,
he would sit in the back and I say,
man, come, come up. You know when,
when I do this Q and a answer some
questions and you know, I'm thinking, Hey,
if something goes sideways I'll just
be able to cover for him. No big deal.
You know, somebody asks a question and
JP kind of gives me a look like, Hey,
well I'll answer this.
And I was like, okay,
you don't go ahead and I'll just cover
for you. She just gives an awesome answer.
I'm like, okay, I'll sit down now. And
it's the same thing with you. I was like,
you know, you're thinking, okay,
where's he going to go with this?
Where this is a tough question or
whatever and boom, here you go. You know,
fire for a fact. Um, and,
and both those two events happened
really close together for me and for me,
it was in,
I call actually called leaf,
I think it was the next day or is it
might've been that evening. And I said,
hey, you know, we're good to go.
Like we are not going to have to do all
of this ourselves because Dave and JP
can do this. They get it. They can,
they can do it in, which was, you know,
everybody in their own, I don't want
to think it's arrogance, but it's,
it's just you don't see it. And so
you kind of think, how is Indian,
you know what it's like when
you're in command to something.
That's one of the really hard
things to do is let go. You know,
and life's talked about this all the time.
You know,
when I'd be watching him rollout on
out the gate for his first mission,
I done all kinds of missions like that.
And here he's going out to this first
one that he's in charge of and you're
thinking, man, I should just go, I
want to go. I don't want to go in.
And then you know,
two hours it comes back and you're like
high five [inaudible] then you go, cool.
I don't have to be the guy that goes
every time. And so when, when I saw you,
when I saw JP and I was like, this
is awesome. I called life and said,
we are going to be good to go
on other guys. They can do this.
They can bring the same message,
they can bring the same passion and power
and knowledge. And that was very, very,
you know,
refreshing to me.
And bottom line is the experiences are
the same. I mean they're not exactly the,
but
the experience in Ramadi is the same.
And then the experience that we had
throughout our military career and now you
get to see what it's like interacting
with businesses and you see all those
similarities. So that was
uh, that was a big day.
And so in case I haven't
made this clear yet,
Dave now is with us part of the echelon
front team and doing what we do,
helping businesses with their
leadership in their companies.
So it's awesome. It's awesome having you
on. It's huge for me. I told you I left,
you know, I left the
Marine Corps. I'm like, ah,
there's something missing and I can't,
I can't stay in marine cause
there's something missing.
Well you leave the Marine Corps like how
in the hell am I going to recreate that
thing that I'm looking for?
Not In the military.
It's all I know is that's the place.
And that was my biggest,
my biggest fear was I'm just going
to go like go to work, you know,
go do some thing that,
so I was worried like I
got to find something and
that's part of the reason why
that first Gig with you guys in the back.
I was like, holy cow manner. You've,
you've got to be kidding me.
It's all those things you just discussed.
All those things.
I spent my whole life living and
breathing and learning and then it's what
people like Lavan Jocko from where we're
going, we're going to do this together.
Yeah, so good deal, Dave.
Are you kidding me dude?
I wasn't on monster.com searching for
employment opportunities. Lave called me.
He said, come to Vienna. I'm
like, oh, okay. My head was
a million miles away, man.
I'm just working through paperwork to
drop my letter out to leave the marine
corps like very hastily with
no, no plan B. There was no,
I'm leaving to do this.
You can ask. He like,
there was zero conversation about what
I'm going to do and I came back from that.
I'm like a,
here's the plan.
And it duty was instantaneous for me.
It was instantaneous.
And then to be able to share that
message and believe it and have all those
feelings and in a, in a totally
different way and Dork with you guys.
Yeah. And it's cool too because you
get that kind of a, for you top gun.
For me working in the training
command where it's like,
oh look at what I already talked
about you, you have this experience.
And when I was getting out I was saying,
what am I going to do with this thing?
What am I going to do? But I got all
this knowledge and I thought, okay,
well I guess I'll put it in a cruise box
over here, lock it up and it'll, it'll,
it'll fade away and turn into dust.
But when you realize that you can
take what you learned and you can,
you can apply it to all these,
you know,
civilian civilians and civilian companies,
it's pretty,
it's a pretty damn good feeling
to have and to be out, go,
go out and do it on a regular basis.
And one of the best things about it
is you get to see the improvement.
You get to see teens.
And again,
it's kind of like when you show up and
you see the leadership issues you're
having, it's like you're seeing,
you know what the future is,
you know how to fix it and
you just go,
this is going to be fun.
And you get to see these people grow
and learn and improve and get better.
And if there are already good,
you get to see them become awesome.
If they're not doing great,
you get to see them improve their
position and then move in that direction.
So it's definitely rewarding from that
aspect. I know you've already seen that.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
You know that book and the lessons and
you talk to me about the title of the
book is how US Navy Seals lead and win.
You know,
I'm top my life is what I learned
from top gun in the Marine Corps.
It just so happens, like we
said, it's exactly the same.
I have my own long list of my personal
experiences with those things,
but I was telling you the day
like the concepts, it's identical.
And so there's no like big leap in my,
my God,
how am I going to get there from how my
name brace? This is, oh yeah. Oh my God.
That's exactly what I've been doing for
the last 23 years. Only my stories, this,
this and this and this is my view of
that. So, uh, again man, it was just,
it was so easy to just see it and
go, this is, this is legit. I am,
I'm all, I want to, I want
it right now. Hey, slow down.
Like, no, 100%. I don't want,
I don't want to go look for, well
this is still happening, right? Yeah,
it's happening. So try not to oversell
it, sell it a little bit, but it was,
I was all in five minutes in a day one.
It's been been awesome so far.
And speaking of echelon front,
if you want to have us come work with your
company or with your team or whatever,
you can,
you can email info@echelonfront.com.
If you want us to speak for an event,
don't contact the speakers bureau,
his contact info@echelonfront.com.
You'll find us there.
Um,
also we have the muster coming up.
Speaking of echelon front,
the muster number zero zero two,
it's going to be in New York City.
By the way.
Dave will be there.
He's going to do a little
presentation cause you know what,
but he's going to do a presentation.
He's going to PR you can
do about the Ooda loop.
That's an a lot of questions about
the Ooda loop is to do it. President,
he's going to do a presentation about
the Ooda loop. It's going to be 14 hours.
Uh, no. He's going to talk, you
know, he's going to talk about his.
MMM.
His perspective on a lot of
this stuff and Ooda loop.
A lot of times people ask me about the
Hulu because I do talk about it and I've
said, I said a few, you know,
a month ago or something.
Somebody asked me about and I
said, you know what, I'm going to,
I'm going to bring you a professional,
a professional with that specific
information. So Dave, we'll be talking.
Obviously life is going to be there.
Jp is going to be there clearly as well.
Jp is going to be doing a
little presentation as well
from his perspective on
some things. Echo Charles, you know,
Echo Charles is going to be there.
Will he be doing a presentation?
I don't know. Time will tell. I
don't know what he would present on.
Maybe just present on
bring all the intensity.
Need to do a presentation on cruising.
Yeah, balance things out a little bit.
Back to throw a little, balance it at
that dichotomy right there and yeah,
so monster May 4th and fifth,
New York City Marriott,
Grand Marquis.
It's an event about leadership.
It's tools for Lucia leadership.
It's about understanding,
understanding leadership and getting those
reps in and hearing all the different
angles. That's what makes you good at
it. Of course it's live. Of course.
There's no backstage,
there's no diva green room
that will be hiding in saying,
bring me some green m and m's for my
next set. No, that's not happening.
We won't be hiding is going to be all
of us together. We'll be learning,
becoming better leaders.
We will see you there.
Now as far as this podcast goes,
Echo Charles,
maybe you could present us at this time
with some information on if anybody does
want to support this podcast,
how they could do a small presentation,
small presentation. Who is
that with? The green m and M's.
That thing you said with the
agreement, that was somebody, right?
Still going to be rough.
It's David Lee Roth,
and I actually know the story behind this.
There's a reason why he did that.
They would have a, it's called
a, I forget what it's called,
but when you go to somewhere,
oh, it's called a rider, right?
So you get a contract and the
contract comes with a rider and says,
this is the things that we need.
So what David Lee Roth from van
Halen would do is he would say, Hey,
I want,
you know,
seven bowls of m and m's with no brown
m and m's in them or green or whatever.
I think it was brown, but
he'd say, no brown m and M's.
And this sounds like a ridiculous
request, right? I mean, who would,
who would possibly want
that? Blah, blah, blah. Well,
David Lee Roth did it for a reason. Why
do you think he did it? Can you guess? No.
Can you guess? Because check it
out. Think of how simple this is.
He's doing a concert one night.
He's doing a concert to light later
to concert three nights after that.
So he's on the road hitting these concert
venues and there's all this stuff that
has to be set up and all the stuff that
lights and sound and soundboards and
special effects and ramps and all this
stuff's gotta be set up and it's gotta be
set up right.
When he would show up if the seven bowls
of m and m's were laid out and there's
no brown m and m's in him,
he wouldn't have to go and inspect
everything cause he knew that they were
paying attention
and if he got there
and it wasn't that way,
he knew that these people had an
issue with attention to detail.
And so now he had to be a go and
scrutinize and make sure everything was in
place the way it was supposed to be.
Little lesson learned from David Lee Roth,
a little test test test m
and m's. Teth. Interesting.
And by the way, that story that I just
told, that may be a 100% urban myth,
but I know I heard it from somebody
I thought, I think it's true.
I'm sure somebody,
I'm sure
our listeners will tell us
where that can be referenced.
For some reason I thought it was somebody
else and that's just how they were,
or their OCD or something like that.
I don't know. But either way. Hey,
you're, so you think about like, um,
the reason you were such an important
asset given your skill set as a forward
air controller,
that's what it's called is
because essentially you have
all this expertise while
you're in the air and you can bring
all that brain and eyes to the ground.
Yeah. That's why you're better than
your will. Yeah, I mean, absolutely.
I didn't really pick up on that until
kind of later. I was like, Dang,
that's pretty advanced.
If you think about any,
any aspect,
I mean it's like if you,
that's why in the corner of a
mixed martial arts match, oh,
oftentimes there'll be a striking coach,
right?
There'll be a Jujitsu coach and
they'll be a wrestling coach. You know,
that they'll have those specific guys
in there and sometimes they'll bring a
specific guy in to corner.
Like,
like Dean Dean has been brought in to
corner guys that are going against a
specific Jujitsu person because they want
to get a little bit of that expertise.
Same fundamental concept here. Okay. Hey,
when we started this podcast, I needed
somebody that knew how to press record.
Thethe same thing,
identical all those years of pressing
record and then stop and then record
again.
I'm kind of like good deal echo in a way.
Same thing and doing the same thing as
Dave really when it comes down to it.
Speaking of doing good things,
so that was a big like breath.
I'd you better say so back for right
now. Actually, I'm not gonna say a lot.
I felt like I really went deep
into the Krill oil analogy.
The nightclub Omega threes don't do
that. Yeah. You know the love of God.
I feel like the mess.
That was a good analogy.
That was a perfect analogy. She was
excellent. In fact, it was so good.
I wouldn't touch it. You get what I'm
saying? That's exactly what I'm saying.
You know that there's too
much of a good thing anyway.
If you didn't know what Krill oil is,
it's a little like what shrimp things,
baby shrimp. You extract the oil and
it's getting as good for your joints,
the Omega threes and that
they're good for returns. Anyway.
In regards to supplementation,
which I'm down for now. By the way,
I mean supplement person,
not all supplements,
just the key ones, joint, uh, maintenance,
whatnot. Anyway, get them from on it.
That's the best ones.
Everyone knows that factually.
So if you want a 10% discount on that,
good on it.com/delco
I want to talk about the
sodium in the water situation.
I got a feeling we're just going
to hear it over here. Yeah. So,
so while Dave and I are
talking the podcast,
are you just over here just dreaming
up just where you're going with this.
When you say Echo, how can you
support, I'm thinking, Dang,
you day's been controlling all this
stuff and going to the top going,
you've been doing your stuff
and I'm watching like sodium
in the lake videos you
ever, do you ever watch those? What
you have to do what I'm doing? Yeah. So
anyway, the more I watched those, the
better analogy I realize it is, you know,
with the Amazon Click through things.
So people want to support the spot gas
in easy way. Click through the website,
Jocko, podcast.com this little support
tab, click on it. Do Your Amazon shopping.
Some people are smart when they do this.
Clever,
they figured out which I met,
I think I mentioned or I,
I know I mentioned it long time ago,
but what they do is they click on it.
Then they save that URL
into their bookmarks. Some
people were smart like that.
Yeah. Like this says
Amazon, so on the right,
on my bookmarks bar just as Amazon
and that's what I did, right.
I did that. Yeah. Oh, hey man,
that's a smart thing to do. Porch.
Yeah. Good way to sport before
you do your Amazon shopping.
Click through there and uh, you
know, that's a really solid,
solid way to support a small action
with the click through. Big Reaction,
big support. There it is.
Also, subscribe to Youtube.
If you're in the videos,
you liked the video version of this
podcast or little excerpts that all put on
there.
If you don't want to watch necessarily
the whole podcast at any given moment,
little excerpt, you can take some
value from that. Also, sharable,
sharable. Yeah. Yeah. You don't
want to share with your buddy, hey,
I heard you've got this situation
going on. Just watch this two hour,
48 minute podcast. And I'm
like, no, people don't have
that kind of patience. No.
And for a lot of the time, the time
before they're going to work that day,
you know, they can listen to
four or five minutes, not there.
Like I got this guy that's really,
you know,
treat me bad at work. What should I
do? Cool. Is what you do. Ignore it.
Outperform next. Exactly. Yeah.
As opposed to hey, listen to this episode
number, whatever it is, two hours,
19 hours and do it. It's not
doable. It's not realistic.
Also, Jack was a store. It's called
chocolate store. Uh, we got a new design.
That's all I'm going to say about it. Um,
so yeah, going there. Jocko store.com. Um,
that's a, you know, a new new me, a new
shirt. New Tee shirt. Tee Shirt. Yeah.
A new tee shirt is out at this
time. It is currently, yeah. Dang.
This was kind of like a bullshit
of crowd get after it yet.
This is like a crowd.
I wouldn't consider it crowdsourced idea,
but you know how crowd demanded.
Yeah. You know, I was like,
hey that put this on the shirt.
Put this on a shirt and make sense.
Make sense though.
We're kind of extrapolated all the ideas
that I thought were good master move
over the ideas that I heard from you you
thought were good and boom there it is.
New Design up currently legit. Yup. Jocko.
store.com. Anyway, there's
some school stuff. Good for uh,
there's stuff for women and
rash guards there stuff.
Rash guards. No, I that was
the interruption of thought.
So like a rash guards. We have the new
registrar for brainy after this one. Yeah,
no, no, it's okay. Good.
You know how you think like five things
at once and they're all like jockeying
to see which ones are going to come
through and that's what happened there.
The rash guard a thought came in in one.
Anyway,
I think I'm going to put in new rash guard
one, um, design out as well. But anyway,
rash guards, if you want 19%
improvement in performance,
all aspects of performance,
all yeah, that's mental,
physical, emotional as well.
Double blind tested by the way.
Yeah.
I think like quadruple blind and
not blame testing all that stuff.
Psychological warfare.
If you're having weakness in maintaining
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things,
listen to psychological warfare.
Yeah.
I got, I just got interviewed the other
day and it was, uh, the guy, you know,
he sent me up to this question, you
know, hey, what do you do when you're,
you're in a situation where you've got,
you know,
you want to go to the gym or you're,
you're supposed to do some hard task for
work or you're trying to do something
to improve yourself and
you don't want that.
That mindset comes in where you just,
you just don't want to do it. You know?
What should you think
people should do then?
Yeah. And I said, do it anyway. Right.
And then it was all
quiet because he thinks I'm going
to give this big explanation,
but there is no big explanation.
The explanation is, oh,
this stuff is hard. Yeah.
I can't make that thing easier for you.
I cannot make 20 rep squats any
easier for you. I can't do it.
They're going to be hard. In fact,
they're going to suck and I can't make,
nothing I can do is going
to make it easier for you.
You know what you have to do to
do it anyways. It's kind of like
I told this to jade,
that exact situation where that thing
that you just said where it's even if you
don't feel like doing it, you still
want to do it and all this stuff. So,
but your body is like, oh, it's
kind of running on auto like okay,
compare it to like a video camera,
right?
Where you put the settings
on auto and it'll,
it'll adjust with how it's feeling and
that's how it's going to handle any
situation. The light kind of goes
down. It kind of adjust how it feels.
You know that to deal with this situation.
So if you're running on auto and you
don't feel like dealing head on with this
workout, these squats, you'd
going to maneuver around.
It just kind of automatically
know you've got to turn it
to manual. Manual can be like, I don't
care if they're heart squats, easy squats.
What I want to do and this is
what we're doing. Yes, exactly.
So it's like a manual mind control.
Just control your own mind. Yeah,
he's talking about that.
Don't do it on like the automatic
because your body wants to rest. Really.
It wants to rest week. Your buddy wants
to rest every single day. Actually.
You got to turn it from model to man
and you can get information like this in
psychological warfare,
iTunes, the artist's name,
Jocko, Jocko Willink, the artist.
I never thought that I would be,
I thought you had to paint something or
sculpt something to be an artist. Yeah,
I fought that.
I think now I put something on iTunes.
Then they just have no urine artists now
that
they're really stretching the words on
that. But yeah, man, if you're, you know,
if you're slipping on the Diet,
waking up in the morning
and you want to hit snooze,
maybe Postville at my workout
and you want,
how should I say, like a spot to switch
the dial from automatic to manual.
That's what it is. So search psychological
warfare on iTunes, Jocko Willink,
get after it. It's a war on
weakness. Yeah, big time.
You know when you're clicking
through Amazon, by the way,
you can get and Jocko white tea
there on Amazon and you know
when you get it, I'm just gonna
say this, when you get it,
you will see,
and I'm going to give you one word just
to kind of what to what to anticipate.
Just just think about this dead lift.
That's what you're going to be.
That's what's going to come to come
to mind with the Jocko white tea.
It's going to be going up a lot.
So, and that's, by the way, again,
quadruple blind double testing
that you're going to bring your,
you know, minimum. What's the lightest?
I think the minimum that you're going
to get dead lifting is eight thousand
eight thousand pounds upon,
so get on that.
You can also preorder way the warrior
kid, it comes out May 2nd. By the way,
it just came out on iTunes as one of the
most anticipated books of the spring.
Oh Dang it got listed right.
How do you imagine that right kid's book.
Now all of a sudden we're talking
most anticipated book of the spring,
which means people are waiting for it and
they've ordered it. So if you want it,
order it now.
Now I'm going to tell you there's some
people that are not looking forward to
this book coming out. They
are not anticipating. You
know who those people are?
Beliefs. Oh yeah. Bullies
aren't looking forward to it.
I'll tell you who else isn't. Looking
forward to this, coming out. Donut makers,
people that make donuts, you
know the Gig is up. Weakness.
You know weaknesses like a creature,
like a unique creature. Yeah.
He's not looking forward to this book.
Come out because all of
those things are going down.
All those things are trembling.
Make those things tremble harder.
Order way. The warrior kid for
your kid, for your neighbor's kid,
and for yourself,
you will dig it.
Also, discipline equals
freedom. The field manual,
it's coming out in October 17th I
know it seems like a long time away,
but I'm telling you, you should preorder
it now. Why? Because when you preorder it,
you will then know that it is coming
and when you know it is coming,
you will begin to prepare for it mentally
and physically for this book to arrive
on your doorstep.
You want to be ready mentally and
physically because when you get this book,
you will have to do certain things,
namely get after it. Yeah, that one.
Extreme ownership. Of course the
book, you can get it right now.
You don't have to wait at all, not just
for you, but for your team, your spouse,
your boss, your babysitter,
your mother in law.
You know she needs a copy of that.
She needs it. It takes ownership.
So grabbing a copy, just be gentle with
it. You don't have to throw it at her,
but maybe just place it on her desk.
So she can read it because the more people
you get in the game and start taking
ownership of things, the better your
life's going to be straight up. Now,
if that isn't enough of us,
you can find us
active on the interwebs,
Twitter,
Instagram and if you on it,
look at that Facebook [inaudible]
we gonna be there as well.
Dave is at David Burke.
Echo is at echocharles
and I am at Jocko Willink.
Echo. Charles, any closing words? Uh,
I feel like we should talk about the
movie top gun a little bit, right?
No one question on quit. And you know
how like when you watch top gun right in,
of course maverick, that's your
guy or goose. That's your guy.
Did you like iceman
cause he was pretty dope.
I'm talking about right. Absolutely.
Who doesn't like guys man, boom. See?
Absolutely. There it is. Yup. Simple
as that. That's your one question.
Real fun question yet or did you ever
buzz the tower? You know what I'm saying?
That never happened is that fake.
You can't really do that
and I can't really do that.
You can be in a ton of trouble as
they say. You can do anything once.
You can do that once and then
what you're out. You're out.
But not if you're maverick.
Awesome.
Dave men, obviously. Thanks Tom
for coming on. And you got me.
You got any closing remarks and
I'm sure we'll do this again.
And when you listen to this,
you'll think of a bunch of stuff
that we should have said on this one,
but anything else you want to wrap it up
with for today? Yeah, man. First thanks.
This was awesome. Uh, I've been thinking
about this for a couple of weeks now.
We've been talking about it and I was
super fired up to be here and this was,
this was awesome. Um, you know,
we were talking about it just briefly and
I mentioned it, you know, my, my wife,
obviously I talked about the
things that they went through.
So my wife and my mom,
he lives, or my family.
Those are folks that have
endured to whatever degree
that when you were removed,
I think when you're on deployment
and you do this stuff, it's hard,
but it's actually in some ways harder
for the people that you leave behind
because they don't know what's going on.
They're just waiting and wondering and,
and dealing with it and they're
kind of holding their breath.
I remember a story that Whitney
told me when I was deployed,
I didn't think about any of this stuff.
I'm a buddy in Neil's that come
to the house. He was gone and, uh,
he couldn't get in the house and he,
he was knocking on the window,
which was by the front of the House
and kind of ringing the doorbell.
And it was late at night,
like not a time that somebody should
be at the door and she didn't want to
answer the door.
And she's telling me this stuff.
You don't think about that stuff
until you get back in here.
The stories cause you don't really think
about what your family's going through
because you're busy and
you're doing your thing,
and she talked about the thing that she
hated the most was people knocking on
the door because she was always just
sort of a tiny bit paranoid that it was
going to be somebody coming
to tell her about me.
You know Chris, Chris's mom, Kathy Leon,
who's someone I don't even have the
words to describe how much I love her and
admire her and it's not
just about her loss.
She obviously she had to answer
that call. Well, you know,
she had to take that call on June 20th,
2006 she took that phone call,
but that woman has endured the loss of a
marine who sacrificed herself on behalf
of the entire country and my relationship,
the irony of all this is that I would not,
I would not have a
relationship with Kathy.
It Chris wasn't killed and I would give
anything to take that day back and bring
him home. I would trade any of it, but
the goodness that comes out of that,
there's always,
there was always some goodness if you
look forward hard enough that comes out of
all this stuff on and the loss
and the things that you sacrifice.
And I know Cathy has certainly
is listening in and I
never anticipated having a
relationship with, with someone like
that based on those circumstances.
But my relationship with
her is really important. Uh,
and what she has done for the
country is really important.
And if you look hard enough
in the worst situations,
you find something that's good.
And my relationship with her is
really good and I would really,
it would be wrong for me to go through
this whole Todd cast and talking to all
those things to without
acknowledging that goodness with her.
So I wanted to mention that.
Well Dave,
obviously thanks for,
thanks for coming on.
I know we've been talking about this for
a while and it's great to have you on
it.
Thanks for sharing your story with
us. The story of you, but marine
fighter pilot a forward air controller
but also a son.
A brother,
my father,
a person,
and yeah,
thanks for sharing the story
of Corporal Chris Leon.
A marine,
no doubt
a hero without question,
but
let us remember.
Let us always remember that these men,
these men we call warriors,
these men,
we call soldiers.
These men we call marines.
These men we call heroes,
but us never forget
that they're people,
sons and daughters,
husbands and wives and
brothers and sisters.
Okay,
let us not forget that they're there.
Not only courageous and vigilant and
bold and aggressive and inspiring,
but they're also funny
and outrageous and flawed like any of us,
and that they're loving
Ben loved,
and that there are people,
people who left behind people.
Then those that are left behind.
Never Forget.
Bye. Chris Leones mom, Kathy Leon
who wrote,
but no
on his memorial page back in 2008
and she said,
hi baby.
Another difficult day to
face without you here.
I never thought that Memorial
Day would be in memory of you.
My dear, sweet, beautiful sun.
It's been one year,
11 months and five days,
so close to two years.
Then I cannot bear the thought.
We honor you by flying the flag every
day and we will place you are American
heroes tribute banner
for all to see tomorrow.
Of course,
we will cry more tears
and maybe find a smile
or laugh as we remember.
Your deep voice,
great smile,
joking, sense of humor and
the love you show to us.
Our hearts are forever
empty and broken without you
miss you so much and love you more.
All our love
mom and dad,
remember?
Yeah,
remember Major Henry l Rod.
Remember Corporal Christopher Leon.
Remember those like them who have fallen.
Remember them as warriors.
Remember them as heroes,
but always,
always remembered them
as people
remember them.
Until next time,
this is Dave and deco and Jocko
out.